good morning uh committee members we
have four amendments that are coming
around
take one pass it around
i don't think we've seen them up front
here yet so
uh if there's x pass around there's and
and uh
we'll be taking those up after we deal
with the bill we haven't to be heard
here right off
okay as soon as those amendments are
spread around the table here we're gonna
open up the hearing
hello
okay i think we're ready to go here uh
the amendments which you got you also in
that bundle you note there is one for
353 and that's the bill we're ready to
go ahead with but that 353 in your
bundle
is a germane amendment so we'll deal
with that at that time
this uh hearing rate today is for the
non-germane amendment which is being
added to
uh 353 and the germain amendment is
relative to the educational professional
standards board and relative to the
composition of cooperative school boards
and i'd like to welcome representative
cordelli who is going to be presenting
the bill or the amendment thank you
thank you mr chairman and colleagues
for the record glenn cordelli
representing tuftonboro moultonborough
on sandwich in the beautiful lakes
region
this
amendment
is the result of a prior bill that we
had passed unanimously out of committee
but was pulled from the consent calendar
and
ultimately tabled
a lot of work has been done
on
this
amendment and i'd like to go through
a couple of the key points briefly for
you
first
the bottom of page one
i think one of the key points is that
if
the uh
co-op
school board
has a representative from a particular
town
the town should elect that member
not the entire cooperative school board
will be voting for the
member from one individual town
it'll be up to the voters in that town
to elect their representative to the
school board
apportionment
apportionment of school
cooperative school board members shall
be done on the basis of population
based on one person one vote doctrine
so that if you had
a large town
and three smaller towns
the large town might have three
members to the cooperative board and the
smaller three towns would have one
member each um and i think a speaker
following me will have some examples of
how that works out uh form some existing
school districts
over on the top of page two
[Music]
pretty much the existing languages
maintained in that
if the cooperative school board
wants to come up with a different
member
selection process
uh they still have the ability to
present that
to the state board of education for
approval which is an existing statute
in terms of timing
the composition of the school board
shall be put in place in accordance with
this section by july 1 2025
so that
no
members who were just elected let's say
this
past
march or
some and maybe maybe in a few weeks
would be affected
but if
a member's term does expire prior to
that july 1 2025 date
um they would be elected pursuant to
this uh section and that the members of
at least me the voters in their town
would elect them
then at the
lines 20-23
apportionment
will be reviewed and possibly updated
every 10 years
in accordance with the
federal census
just as
we
are redistrict and reapportioned
based on the census every 10 years
i think that that
adds a
very fair
process
to cooperative school board membership
and a very key one also in that
as we've seen with some of these uh
agreements
and some of these
boards
population shifts have occurred
but no change has been made to the way
members are elected
and it's i think an unfair process to
everyone
um so i think those are the
three
key elements um to this uh amendment and
i think that others behind me might have
some more information as i sample some
good examples of how this would work for
existing districts
thank you very much representative
cordelli are there questions of the
representative yes representative miler
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
two questions first of all
uh where does that why does this arise
at this point in time is my first
question
the second question is
i believe
we have two other
bills that are on study
regarding cooperative districts
and why wouldn't we put this issue
with that study
to deal with the whole issue of
cooperative districts because it's a
it's a complicated
concept that we're dealing with here
and they're trying to deal with it in an
isolated way rather than trying to put
it in to the
total study that we already have
committed to so those two are my two
questions
um thank you uh i think that
as you've said this has been a
complicated issue and every year
it seems we have bills related to
cooperative school boards a lot of which
has been centered on
funding and withdrawal of cooperative
school board
districts from from the cooperative
in a number of districts
this year
it really became apparent
about the
small towns
being
really denied a say in their
representatives the cooperative school
board
because of the a larger district
dominating the vote because basically
the entire district votes for that one
towns member
i for instance
you know living in tufts borough um
really have
little knowledge of the candidates
running in effingham a small
town
and i don't think it's fair to the
people running in effingham that i
should have a vote
on who is going to represent effingham
so i think that that
really spurred a lot of the discussion
about
membership and in an attempt to do uh
something related to membership um
uh irregardless of of where
uh study committees go and where the
whole process of withdrawal and funding
um
goes with uh those other two issues
thank you are there fo are other further
questions yes reps and tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
uh when you say a number
of cooperative districts could you uh
tell me
like in a ballpark figure of who you've
heard from which cooperative not which
clock the districts but
uh have there been other just you know
how many out of this number have
actually approached you and said that
they are upset with how things are i i
think a number of districts have
approached different members um of the
house um i was uh
most
interested in uh one of my local
districts which is a cooperative school
board um and that's the uh one i
mentioned in terms of effingham um
members of being elected to the school
board
so there's there's one can you i need a
ballpark figure like zero to five five
to ten
i i don't know how relevant that is um i
just know that uh different members of
the house have been um approached uh on
this subject um and i've heard from
several of them
i just
just as a follow-up i just um the reason
i want to know the number
is that you know in my area that the
cooperative district is pretty settled
it's been settled there for 55 years now
and
i just uh you know we don't make
legislation
based on one or two instances and we
have a number a large number of
cooperative districts and so i wanted to
know you know the the reason i'm
pressing this is i want to know
a ballpark figure are we are we
legislating for just one or two
cooperative districts that are
disgruntled or are we
trying to make a
legislation that's going to affect all
the cooperative districts
um and and a lot of you know the
majority of them are settled and i want
to remain settled i i think that uh over
the years we've heard from
many people
many many members of this house who are
disgruntled
with the way the cooperative school
boards
work and the whole concept
so i think this is nothing new but this
is an attempt to
address one aspect of cooperative school
boards that being the membership
representative luno no answer
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much representative cordelli um for
bringing this forward and for taking my
question uh i want to go to the top of
page two
and explore what you mean by um
option b
which reads such other methods of
selection of cooperative school board
members as maybe approved by the state
board of education and i was wondering
if you could explore that um what
what other methods
could be in your mind
um
thank you um
this basically is existing language in
the statute now no no no
excuse me representative it's not
existing language because you you've
struck compatible with proportional
representation one man one vote if if i
if i could finish i can mention that um
yes we uh struck that one portion out
because we feel that that's covered
in previous section
a
the proportional representation
so this could
address
existing districts who maybe have an
at-large member or multiple at-large
members if they wanted to keep that
method of selection
they could
send that to the state board of
education for approval that would be one
example
follow-up quality chair so um so just to
be clear
in um in in the amendment here
um
to
195 19a
uh
roman one
roman one now consists of according to
based on the amendment consists of two
parts an a or a b
so what's covered in a
is not necessarily covered in b and
covered what's in b
is not necessarily bound by what's an a
because your choice is a or b
so so looking at b
let me give you an example and tell me
where and be
it would not be authorized let's say the
commissioner of education
selects the cooperative school board
members
uh if i understand your question you're
um
uh proposing that the commissioner of
education is gonna choose the school
board members for a cooperative school
board is that the question so i'm not
proposing it but let's say the secretary
the commissioner of education
decided to select the um the school
board members
um where in b would would that be
prevented from happening
uh i think that is a uh
uh
i'll say hypothetical um but i i think
is uh very extreme that uh i think is um
uh
way out there and but
hold on hold on one one more follow-up
and then that's it okay
any approve any a board
cooperative school board plan
would be approved by the state board of
education i think that uh it has to come
from the cooperative school board um to
be approved by the state so let's say it
comes from the chair of the cooperative
board and the chair the chair of the
board would like to select um uh who's
on the the school board with her would
that be allowed under b and if not could
you please explain how a and b a or b
um i'm sorry how b would prevent that
um it would have to be approved by the
state board of education and i'm sure
that they would look into
the existing situation and
the uh wishes of the cooperative school
board
as a whole not just one person being the
chair
oh you add your one follow-up
i i have a question for you and it's a
referencing the same section of law on
the on the second page there at the top
on lines one through three i'm in a
cooperative district myself right now
and if we decide that that district
is fine and functioning well
um then we could petition the
uh commissioner or the state board for
approval to continue and would not have
to abide by other
sections that are in this law is that
correct
yes that is uh the way that the uh
legislation was uh drafted and that is
the intent as well
further questions
yes representative woodcock
thank you um chairman thank you
uh two if i may one to follow up to
shamrock ladd's question is the opposite
uh equally uh accurate that the
commissioner could say
no
it's the state board who has approval
because they both say no
yes i imagine so if
for instance um if i could finish uh if
for instance um a
a proposal came from just one member of
the
cooperative school board uh i would
anticipate that the state board
might well uh say no well i was my
attempt
just trying to be clear rather than
cordelia and representative ladd's
comment he if i understood it right he
was saying we have a robert school board
everything's running terrifically
everybody's happy
and they petition could the whoever the
charge here the state board could say no
we want all the school boys to be the
same
under this raw
is that accurate
um
i would say it's possible not um
likely
but um okay that's fine yep one more
you had two well i was follow up on
yours representatives
i'm gonna follow up on my own i got
another question
it's a general question rather than
quinelli to which i don't know the
answer uh do
these school boards if reapportionment
occurs
does that change
the financial mechanism for
reimbursement within the district no
had no impact on financial markets no
thank you thank you everyone appreciate
that represent moans
sorry i had to get my technical advisor
over here to turn his microphone off man
just
touch the uh no no the daisy chain no no
will not
uh thank you representative for taking
my question so
for my own sense of clarity
page two line one
such other method of selection of
cooperative school board members
as may be approved by the state board of
education
so
the state board of education
should this pass would be given the
authority
of approving a selection method for
school board members
that
does not involve
voting for those school board members
they could be appointed as opposed to
being voted in
i
i think that's another hypothetical
that's uh very likely uh
very unlikely to occur um the uh intent
is that uh as i
laid out um initially is that uh
members within the town elect
their
member to represent them at the
cooperative school board that's the uh
underlying principle um that we have in
in this follow-up mr chair yes um right
i don't i don't debate what you're
saying about the proportional uh
assignment of the number of school board
members what i'm saying is that that's a
totally separate issue than the state
board of education being given the
authority to appoint school board
members
um
and so i'm wondering
to representative luna's you you know
highlighting of the word or
um
where is the need for this where where i
i understand that people from effingham
may want their own represent
representative on the school board
but who from
effingham came forward and said
gee i think we ought to include a
section that says that if the state
board wants to use an alternative
method they can
the state board can
have an alternate method approved
currently in statute
i don't know if that has happened in the
uh
um
60 plus years of cooperative school
boards
um but that's
existing statute that they have that
ability we do have a number of other
people on testosterone just one more um
i i would have absolutely uh been with
you
representative cordelli until the
portion where compatible with
proportional representation one man one
vote was stricken from
that section
thank you any further questions of
representative cordelli thank you very
much
represented about brahmin
thank you mr chair for the record before
you head out of here i'm going to need a
card from you you got one right there
oh he just gave up
thank you yeah welcome
thank you for the record uh statement
proud of me uh rockingham 19 stratham
so
obviously education's not my area i'm a
ways and means guy but
you know when when the
uh when uh the house bill
that was tabled that you all voted for
19 to nothing
uh i started my conversation with the
chair and the vice chair about this
and we started to look into this whole
issue and we dug out a lot of the
it's very hard to find the actual
uh agreements that
exist around the state there's like 30
co-op boards
and we dug out a lot of them to see what
their makeup is and all of that
so we did a lot of research in the last
month or so since that that tabling
occurred
so
you know on that a and b thing let me
just address that
we put we we changed that so that
only if
a school board doesn't
comply with the the tenants of this bill
that they have an alternative
that they can go to the
to the state
board and
and plead their case
so they have all they have to do is say
look
we have a a a complicated situation here
uh we can't meet all the tenants
and here's why so it's an effect they're
acting like a court saying yeah
we agree with you
you you have a special situation here
and
you know but you have to have an
argument you have to have a reason why
you can't comply and when i show you
some of the examples in a minute
in my handout uh that should become
become clear
so again
it
you know there's two pieces of the bill
really
you know do we want do we want
apportionment to be
fair of the the number of seats per
uh existing there's different language
in the bill but in the bill and current
statutes but existing districts
which really in effect means towns
okay uh the the individual towns or in
the original original districts
versus the co-op district okay
so
so wouldn't it make sense to
at least take a look at it and i and i
looked at a whole bunch of them and in
10 minutes i said you know something
their districts make sense in terms of
the the allocation of seats to the
district so i don't think this is a big
going to be a big burden on on the towns
to to go through the exercise and i'll
again i'll show you some examples to to
show you that but the second piece of
the build that's apportionment the
second piece of the bill really is about
shouldn't shouldn't towns pick
their own
uh
representation
uh there are many examples and one
another question was asked because are
there
other other towns i know obviously i say
16 my town my district uh i was meeting
with some folks in winneconne district
uh the other day they had some real
concerns about how the voting is done
and and
there's got to be many other examples as
well of that i know people in my town
say well
why am i why am i voting for somebody
three times away
i don't know who they are i've been
saying this for a year my years myself
so when i saw this amendment i said well
bro good we got a solution to this why
am i why am i voting for somebody i have
no idea who they are
and i'm i'm being asked to vote for them
so
again this this solves that problem okay
so that's the two pieces of the bill
uh
and then then we talk about
in the bill it like every every town or
existing district should get at least
one seat
okay and you know something when i
looked at at
at a lot of the the town a lot of the
districts that already exists
so you'll see that in examples
uh
you know even even at the federal level
you look at alaska vermont and wyoming
all have populations under uh
762 0169 which equals one seat
and we give them a seat anyway
they get even though
they don't have the population to
warrant one seat we give them seats so
the same thing here and a lot of towns
do that right now
uh
and then proportionality
and you're going to see in one example i
could have shown other examples that not
every town have the seats
allocated proportionally
based on the population i think that's a
reasonable
uh a reasonable thing that we should be
be doing
uh
again an example
and but you have to round you have to
round up you have to round down to the
nearest whole number
uh but i'll give an example the federal
level uh for state rep uh state reps for
federal seats
uh idaho is eligible for 2.42 seats and
rhode island is eligible for 1.44 seats
and they both get two seats
okay so
i i mean
you have to have a little finesse here
but
it's got to be in at least in the
ballpark in the range
um
and again i i'll show you example of one
that has no doesn't have proportionality
uh we talk about purely at large seats
in my mind we we should try to get
rid of as many of the large seats
as we can because those those seats can
i'll show an example here where we can
allocate those seats to the towns
proportionally
why are we gonna why are we making
people vote
for
for for at large people who
you know
it does it does it doesn't make sense so
uh
you know in 19 in the 1990s when it came
to state rep seats
for those who have been around you
remember we used to have big seat big my
my example is when i first got elected i
had three towns that i had to represent
and we had eight reps representing those
eight towns but in the 1990s we had a
constitutional change
that said
we're gonna we're gonna have smaller
smaller districts to the town level and
so now i i'm one of two in my town
a lot easier to campaign a lot easier to
communicate with my constituents
representing just my town and not all
the other the other towns that were
one was exeter which is much larger than
my town
so
so i mean the same principles here
um
i'm going with my notes in this handout
by the way
uh five
uh
so candidates
another tenant of this of this amendment
which is is consistent with
existing in terms of you have to be
uh domiciled
in the town that you're running in that
that that doesn't change but you should
be elected by those domiciled in that
district so that's the thing and there's
so many reasons why
i think it was mentioned earlier it
prevents
we have in my district we have one town
that represents 47 of the vote
so how is my little town of newfields
gonna compete how are they gonna
they can be outvoted every time in terms
of their selected candidate being
selected by another town uh
this will ensure that the that the
town's choice
of a candidate wins
the bill ensures that the town can vote
for someone they know
and not not vote as i was saying earlier
for some stranger in another town
and here's the real issue
the cost and time it's going to take
for somebody running
in new fields for a seat
and his thirty four thousand citizens
new fails is a couple of thousand
and we have to compete and i have to i
have to spend money put signs up in in
six towns
uh and and go out and campaign in six
towns does it make sense
to get elected in newfalls
so
um
and then once
once elected
you know have your your true true
representative government so the new
fields person relates to the new phil
uh
citizens as they call them with with
issues and etc
you see
you know we just passed a bill
house bill 1046 about sullivan county
commissioners
and
they they have three i guess it's three
but they have multiple commissioners
and right now
it's voted
that everybody in that in that county
votes for all three commissioners and we
all
not all of us but some of us voted
to say that doesn't make sense because
seven seven other counties
have
all their commissioners voted by
the commissioner domiciled in their
district and only voted only by
the uh voters in their district so this
is a similar thing that we're talking
about here
and again seven counties already do that
and this would be they would be the
eighth
um
so what we wanted to do is also have a a
road map they have to develop a plan if
there has to be a change
the bill has a plan you have to develop
a plan
people who
were
you know you have to get from here to
there if we change seat this seat goes
from this town to that town now
the person in the seat doesn't get
removed there's a there's a glide path
so that that person would stay in a seat
until it turns up
and then once that occurs that's why
there's a three-year period in which you
can phase in this that existing board
members would not be impacted by any of
this
and of course we maintain
the 15 seat
limit
for co-ops the three-year term limit for
co-ops
uh in other words up to three you can
pick you can have two year terms three
of terms
that doesn't change and the odd number
seat requirement
also applies
i gave an example my first example if
you go to the if you just really want to
look at this
um
this is the uh contouriquet
valley and i think so i think we have
somebody here from kentucky
uh
but it's kentucky valley uh
school district
and they pretty much already
are
their numbers are right on on beam with
all what i just said so if you go to the
first example it says example one
so there's the populations based on the
2020 census they have 18 900 voters
so what's the percent of the voters
peterborough 34 all the way to sharon
1.9 percent
and i and theoretically
if you multiply that the 34 times 18
1800 18 900 it says they require 14.42
seats
but on the other side
and then sharon require 0.25 seats
but what's their current seat allocation
four for peterborough two for atrium etc
and one from everybody else
13.
and it as it turns out
if we if we take the uh percentage
uh uh
of of seats in other words they were
rounding
so they rounded from 4.42 to four which
is a proper rounding
but then we rounded up for sharon
so
they have 34 percent of of the
population but they have 30.77 percent
of the seats which is okay
okay
so
so if if if the child was re-looking at
their numbers based on the current
census
i don't see any change in the
apportionment it would still be four two
one one one one and equal thirteen now
they could choose any time you can
choose to have up to fifteen
but no less than three
basically because you're not gonna have
one and it has to be odd number
so
so so they're already there
now
governor wentworth
is
and i know i know
i know bro brodie desais is here and
he's the one who pulled the bill off the
of consent so i have this one this has
to do with both borosphere and all those
so there's an example
if you look at the current use they have
18 000
uh census as well
and wolfe
wolfborough clearly is the larger player
and ossipee comes behind
and this is their current they chose
years ago to go 1-1 everybody has one
and then go three
three at large
so
so i'm here's an example of
why
you know if i if i'm uh
if i'm brookfield
how do i
aren't i being dominated by wolfeboro in
my head i i think they are i mean they
could they could out maneuver them and
they could pick somebody they like to to
represent them in brookfield
so what this does is
it says brookfield gets to pick their
own
they're given one
and then the numbers work out three two
one one one one to the nine now again
they could change how many they want
they can have more or they can have less
but uh that's up to them
so there's a there's a very easy
solution turns out representative chase
is from wolfeboro he's one of the
at-large
he would at the end of this
his term he'd probably still we could
get reelected
because
there's two more seats in wolfeboro that
he can run for so it's to me it's not a
problem
now the one that i'll the last example
is merrimack valley
uh
this one stood out to me uh that
again
we have now this is a district this is a
district with 14 000
uh citizens
uh the numbers are a lot smaller but
it's
louden and and the bosque are the are
the largest
but
they chose
again
when they formed as a district they
chose two two two two
which
and then it had to be it had to be
odd number so i'm assuming i don't know
this but i'm assuming to make that work
they had to pick another person to make
it 9 11
to make it an odd number of seats
um
so
i mean
here we go
right now to me
they're not
in in compliance with the current
statutes because it's not proportional
these numbers are not proportional
uh to the population
but again if you do
you do a little rounding
you know basically loudoun should have
four boss one should have three webster
should have two and and salisbury and p
and pinnacock should have one
uh to equal the 11. again they could
change what they want so
i think
again
that
but again i i guess it's a it's
philosophical more than anything else
i i just think that
people in their town should vote for the
people they know in their town
uh they do that with our state reps they
do that with the federal congress they
they we don't we have two two
congressional districts we don't we
don't vote
for i'm in district one i don't vote for
who's in district two
and i think it just you think we're
going to get better better candidates
to run
especially in the smaller town if they
know
that they only have to run in their town
to get elected
uh just makes sense
and
let me tell you this big money coming in
we all and i always
you know i always assume that
uh local elections are local
and that school board elections were
were local
and that there wasn't big money involved
well that's changing
they've become partisan now
and
i think we could take some of the
partisanship out of this by by
saying look
small towns have a chance here you you
pick who you want and we'll keep the
partisanship out which equals
partisanship equals bigger money into
these elections
which we shouldn't have so that's why i
support this amendment and uh
i got a few minutes for questions so i'm
i have to share a ways of means today so
i got about two or three minutes here
thank you very much pat uh
representative moffitt thank you mr
thank you represent ryan for all your
hard work uh especially being from
loudoun just noted from your research
that loudness 40 percent of the
population and 18 of the school board
representation so that is a is something
against my attention but
my question
has to do with uh you talked about
sharon uh tiny town in the contour clip
valley uh i used to be a board member
from campton which is part of sau 48
penny baker cooperative district ashland
campton holiness plymouth romney
thornton wentworth it's maybe the
biggest not population-wise but
geographically in the state now uh also
included in penny baker co-op district
uh sau 48 is waterville valley which
says 243 people by the last census even
smaller than sharon but
there's also ellsworth which uh which
its population skyrocketed from 83 to 93
in this latest
so my question is uh given the model
that that we're looking at here uh would
a town or a town it's a town ellsworth
with 93 people would that rate a full
board member
well what i think
even with the confines of this bill
and i i know i have to see whether or
not they had a full board number
again all this is based on the original
districts before the co-ops were when
the ports are being being created they
call them the existing districts there's
no reason why you i'm not
i'm not hundred sure on this but i think
i think you're allowed to combine towns
to create a an existing district
that would be larger that you could say
you could have one vote
that's an option
but you as as as as a as a co-op
district you'd have to make that
determination
and i i think uh representative ladd has
situations like that in his his area as
well
and that's
uh that's part of the thing so if it's
if it's small that's why we have to be
there in this
that look we can't comply with this you
know either we want to
we want to align a couple of the smaller
towns together and create a position for
them
and argue your case i think it would
probably be agreed to
because once we started looking at this
there's so many different permutations
of what we find
district to district
it's it's but but
uh a lot of them will fit the confines
of this amendment
but we we had to provide a way to to be
able to give a district a chance
to
present its case
to say look we tried hard but this
doesn't make sense and
and i i would i would i would argue that
the state board of education are
reasonable people and you give
reasonable arguments that that they
would they would uh
they would agree that any change you
want to make thank you thank you
representative like us
yes i have a sort of a two-part single
question and my question is in your
merrimack valley example
they decided on equal representation
if they're happy
with their equal representation
i guess the first question is
if they're happy with it would they be
able to then bring that
to would they be able to use b bring
that to the state board of education and
say hey we decided on equal
representation we like it nobody is
complaining um can we keep our equal
representation
yeah but i think in this exam yes they
could
but i i would say that it's it's a
harder argument because it's it
it does violate the one-man one vote but
see that's why i'm wondering because you
crossed out
the compatible with proportional
representation one-man one-vote
principle and so with that crossed out
it seems that they would be able to keep
what they have if they want it and so
that was the other part if we put that
back in
they
my right they then wouldn't be able to
keep this agreement and maybe they like
it
uh we went through a lot of iterations
of this amendment
and i i know we had it in there at some
point now i'll let the chair and the
vice chair explain what we did there
when you have your work session or
discussion about this
but but right now
you're not in compliance
i mean they're not they're not in
compliance with even current statute
so that's one way because no because no
one's monitoring this that's the other
reality nobody's monitoring what
these things
and we we're just trying to give a
little little put a little a little bit
more
um
uh contours to the to the the statute
we can thank you
thank you very much i i've got a
question for you i know you got to head
out of here
i'm cheering today too so that's why be
kind to all our bills over there in ways
means
um and looking at the sanborn regional
school district asset was foreign back
in 1965.
it's got kingston and newton
of which there's three members from it
each
three members representing kingston
uh and three from newton
of which that's populations in these
communities are not the same but they
also have one at large
it's making seven that odd number needed
is it then
if they decide we're good with what
we're doing
in accordance with this bill being put
forward could they petition the state
board
for approval of their present format
absolutely that's why we put that in
yeah thank you again
if they have a logical
explanation why they want to do it it
shouldn't be a problem
perhaps santa luna
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much representative browning um
you said you did a lot of homework on on
this and and i appreciate that um the
difficulty and the challenges and in
collecting a number of the uh the co-op
agreements i was wondering though um
obviously you know you're familiar with
the existing law because you've offered
this amendment i was wondering in
example number three
which which you testified to
towards the end and i think has been the
subject of a couple other questions
this is with respect to
their mech valley school district if you
could tell me which um part that was um
um organized under roman one two three
or four
under under current law
oh geez no i i don't then
i'll go i'll go on it's sort of
rhetorical um it's it's under roman four
uh which reads the members of the
cooperative school board shall each be
domiciled in and represent a
pre-existing district
with each president existing district
having at least
one such resident representative but all
members of the cooperative board shall
be elected at large
and and so
so um
when looking at example three
and and what i just read uh established
under the current um roman four
um i i'm just i wanna i wanna challenge
what you said that it's a violation of
the one man one vote and not in
compliance
with current statute um
because
current statute does say that all the
the board shall be elected at large
um which means ever you know uh loudon
gets to vote on
the seats in other
districts
i mean in other towns right it does say
that
but
i i don't see this being proportional
though okay so a follow up on that mr
chair so if if
if
if merrimack valley wanted to change it
under existing law
what's wrong with
what what's currently presented in roman
one roman two or roman three
with respect to um
um
uh cooperative school board um
cooperative school district shall be
divided into single board member
districts according to population with
its nearly equal population in each
district as possible that does not
require at large voting so each district
would be able to elect their own
resident
member or roman three
both roman two and roman three have been
next out um uh also allows uh single or
multi-member districts which i assume
could be divided by town and again not
require at large
voting
why wouldn't
existing law roman 2 or roman 3 satisfy
what you're trying to accomplish with
this amendment
again when we we looked at it we we we
concluded it it didn't i and i can't
recall the exact logic but you know i
think it's important that that the
committee
understand
why
why roman 2 or roman 3 doesn't doesn't
satisfy the option i mean you're using
terms like like give the districts the
chance let them you know choose an
alternative well there's four
alternatives that are laid out in
current law
two of them require at large voting two
of them don't require at large voting
and uh and do allow for uh single and
multi-member districts right but i but
i'm looking to elect their own i look at
it this way though i look at loudoun at
500 residents in penacook at 1273
and i see what i see here is that they
each have two seats so couldn't and i go
how how can that be
one more question yeah i got it i really
don't know
sure but but but but couldn't roman 3
and current law provide what you've got
for proposed seats here yeah and i'm and
i'm just i'm not prepared to answer that
i i
possibly but i'm not prepared to answer
that thank you very much
right i'll take a very clear question
very quickly i just wanted to ask you
when you've been approached by different
folks
knowing how the statute is currently
written
if anything needs to be changed is that
possible though how would they change
that by voting would the larger towns
still overtake the smaller towns
any possible change
would be difficult because the larger
towns will can outvote
the smaller towns and that that's an
issue thank you
thank you
thank you all appreciate it thank you mr
my husband knew you knew your wife also
um i am no longer a representative um
i'm patricia lovejoy and i'm here
actually just representing myself
i am from stratham
the same town as the previous speaker
i have some background in this and that
i served on our regional our cooperative
school board for nine years
it's been a decade since i did that but
i served in the nine years
and
that's right i was elected by all six
towns in my district
and our towns range from
being as small as 1600
as large as a little over 14 000.
i think that being elected by all six
towns made me a better board member
i
every election
and
even during the term
i visited all the towns i
i took part in every
candidate's night i went to
board meetings of the local boards i
also went to board meetings for the
select board so that i knew the towns
better and i think that it's
when i was representing
the entire district i knew the district
much better
part of my concerns or my biggest
problem with this bill
is it is doing away with proportional
representation and
proportional representation is basically
what al almost all of our politics our
elections are based on with the
exception of u.s senate
everything in new hampshire
is based upon proportional
representation
if this bill were to go through looking
at
just the cooperative district that
that i live in and that the previous
speaker also lives in
you would have
one person being elected
by 1700 people
and another person being elected by
um forty seven hundred and you'd be
representing forty seven hundred versus
seventeen hundred
it uh it the proportionality really goes
um really goes out the window
a couple of things that were mentioned
by the last speaker
that you know shouldn't town be able to
pick their own representation
and he specifically mentioned new fields
which is part of the six towns within
that district
on the school board
the representative is required to be
from newfields yes they're going to be
elected in all six towns but they're
required to be in newfield
new fields
is if we look at the state house
is in a district with new market
there is no requirement
that one of the representation one of
the three reps that get elected from new
fields and new market have to be from
new fields
so the way that the cooperative is set
up is you know in effect more fair
um he also represented uh talked about
that county commissioners you know that
that this was sort of the same thing as
county commissioners but it's it's not
even in the county that we're looking at
going to districts the districts are
based upon population
and every 10 years you have to
potentially reconfigure
the
county commissioner districts to be
proportional
let's see
i think that's all i had to say
basically the um proportionality
that part of it just really bothers me
and i said i have a lot of experience
with a cooperative district i'd be
willing to take any questions
thank you and it's good to see you back
here
um
just one uh do you think that this this
non-german amendment uh will make
cooperative districts
more more cooperative or more
uncooperative
you know i having served nine years on
that board in three years on another
school board um i'm not sure that that
the method of picking people
will make it more cooperative or
uncooperative there have been times i've
been on board so they've been extremely
cooperative and i've been
on boards
when
it has been very
uncooperative
and it hasn't been based upon which
towns they were from
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so if i understand your testimony is is
that
by with the current system that we have
that a candidate
can understand
the full breadth of the cooperative
issues
by being elected and then having
served with other districts by looking
at
towns etc
that you have a much broader perspective
than just your own town if you're
elected from just that town
and feeling that you represent just that
town
rather than the multiple towns that are
within a siu is that your testimony that
is my testimony and you know it's it's a
little bit similar to a floaterial i
guess i've
um tended to represent large
uh groups when uh when i was a member of
this body i was
actually from the largest floaterial in
the state i represented as a state house
representative
about 36 000 people
i had
a pretty large four district four town
district and i represented
you know all of the people but i think
that
where with the school board
you are you know you're representing you
know that the six towns
and i
i think if you take a very parochial
view that you're just representing your
town it it does the school board um a
disservice so i
i always felt i mean i know the first
time i decided to run for the co-op it's
like wow i gotta run in all six towns
but
i you know i i did it i went and met
with people in all of the towns and
during the nine years that i was on the
board i fielded questions
from people from all six towns i i never
said to somebody who called me
that well why don't you call the rep
from you know the school board member
who lives in your town i
spoke with any um
any voter or any uh citizen
of the six towns so i i do feel like i
represented all of the all the towns and
i i cannot remember ever taking a a vote
that i was thinking well how would this
be better for stratum it was
what what's best for the students and
the citizens of all six towns
if i may
okay thank you mr thank you welcome back
um so your testimony seemed to indicate
that the current system features
generally satisfactory uh proportional
representation but i want to come back
to my town of loudoun which i mentioned
earlier and which is on the sheet the
information yeah i haven't seen that
but again as i pointed out uh earlier uh
louden has about 40 percent of the
population in uh sau 46 and it has 18
percent of school board now that doesn't
seem proportional to me could you speak
to how 40 i don't know how yours was set
up i mean when ours was set up about a
little over 20 years maybe 24 years ago
um and they can re you know they can
address it if the populations has really
changed
you know exeter got three seats stratham
got two and each of the others got one
even though
they wouldn't if you were looking at um
you know actual numbers new fields would
have never been entitled to you know one
uh one member one ninth because they
were nowhere close to one-ninth of the
population but each of the towns
got
representation
based originally on what kind of what
percent of the population they had and
it's in the charter they can if it
changes drastically it could potentially
end up that
brentwood gets to
and um
and maybe exeter only gets two and
stratum gets to depending upon how the
population changes but
you have to at least in the sau that
uh the cooperative board that i was
a member of and i
will not say that i'm a expert on
anybody else's
cooperative districts i mean it was set
up that each town was ensured
that there would be somebody who is a
resident of that town that's on the
board regardless of how small their
population may be
thank you okay
okay thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
the committee for um
for for letting me testify this morning
and um
i'm sorry for being the one who pulled
this from consent that is um you know
kind of tossed us into the milestone of
all of this so
um
[Music]
let me first say that i am an at large
board member in the governor wentworth
regional uh school district i was
elected this past march i mean i
appreciate all the work that the
committee members have put into this and
some of the other members and it was
very thoughtful but i do have a um
not major concerns but some some i feel
as if legitimate concerns based on
either other state rsas or just based
upon some of the issues that have been
raised today which is how each school
district is very much different than
every other school district especially
cooperative school districts you have
cooperative school districts that range
from you know having two towns all the
way up to you know as representative
moffat mentioned the very large
cooperative district that he was
formerly a member of with campton you
know about six or seven towns uh that
can range from communities with 93
people up to communities with you know
five six seven eight thousand people and
so this can make it kind of tough to try
to create a one-size-fits-all solution
from the state government which you know
i've been in front of this committee
when i've brought forward bills that
made that mistake
and half you know i'm happy that the
board rejected it you know i recognized
i aired in a way and so i'm hoping that
um that sorry the committee so i'm
hoping that we can kind of go through
this and kind of discuss some of the
issues so starting on page one between
lines 12 and 14
the proposed removal of the language
from state rsa
would suggest to state for the first
time as nullifying the bylaws and
articles of agreements for cooperative
school districts established prior to
august 22nd
1971.
at least to my understanding this is not
very orthodox for the state to do uh if
they do do it it's on very rare
occasions
and um it's not very supportive local
controls
over local issues between lines 15 and
23 on page one we would be removing the
four current systems for electing school
board members in all 40 plus cooperative
school districts in the state for
example governor wentworth regional
school district uses a system described
on lines 21-23 i know the election
system that some residents in the exeter
region cooperative school district sau16
desire is described on lines 18 through
20. any voting resident the cooperative
school district can have this voting
system adopted by putting in a petition
warrant article signed by 10 percent of
the qualified voters and passing the
warrant the school board can also put a
warrant on the ballot to do this and as
mentioned earlier and i'll get to it
later but on the top of page two
the section b that was already existing
language any school board can go to the
to the um to the board of education and
get a change with approval of the board
of education so there's three kind of
different ways for recourse for school
districts to address the reapportionment
and the apportionment of their school
board whether it's their districts if
they have multiple districts or the
apportionment amongst the towns within
one large district or amongst all the
districts within their school district a
new section established on lines 24-30
sounds like a reasonable system and
seems legally identical to the system
described in lines 18 through uh 20.
however such a described system might
not be possible as pursuant to rsa 195.
in quotes quote pursuant to rsa 195 end
quote as stated on line 30. it's because
cooperative school boards cannot exceed
50 members on the bro on their board per
rsa1 and e5 colon 19-b this cap on board
members would make truly proportional
representation nearly impossible as in
each person's vote truly counting equal
to another person's vote um this doesn't
mean that would violate the one-person
one-vote doctrine it just means that it
wouldn't be as proportional it was
previously under a um a
large district operating for the entire
district the current language and rsa
195 colon 19-b combined with the
amendment to the amended rsa 195 colon
19-a which is you know lines 24-30
makes it impossible for rural corporate
school districts to abide by the one
person one vote doctrine in some
specific instances as brought up by
representative moffett in the case of
ellsworth with only 93 people be very
difficult to give them one one board
member and then actually you know feels
as if that's going to you know properly
follow the one person one doctrine
system 93 people would get one member
and to make it truly proportional you'd
have to make it so then every other town
you know for 93 people would get one
board member we'd have more school board
members and cooperative school boards in
the 40 districts you know about 40
districts and we do state reps i think
we have enough state reps i don't know
if we need any more cooperative school
board members
there's also the issue in new hampshire
with disproportionate
representation which many have brought
up today and an example is again you
know i keep picking out representative
moffett but his school district the
merrimack valley regional school
district with you know the two people in
each one his community having 45 percent
of the voters and 18 of the seats well
one way that we've remedied that in
districts like for example that
ellsworth is in or in the governor
wentworth regional school district with
a small community like brookfield with
700 in a larger community like wolfeboro
6400 was to say well let's make sure
everyone's vote counts the same so we'll
put everyone in the same district and
everyone will get the same voice in
electing all the members of the board
who make all the decisions from taxation
to education policy to how the buildings
are used to which municipalities are
allowed to use different school
buildings on different days of the years
for example like voting which is a very
common issue we have in the towns of
tuftonboro in new durham typically
school buildings need to be used and the
school board needs to permit those
municipalities to use those buildings
on to page two lines one through three
which already exist in state law i think
there was some confusion on that that
already exists in state law minus a
struck and out part the only part of
state law that's being changed there is
they're striking out the um
specifically the wording is
compatible with proportional
representation one-man one-vote
principle
um
so there are three concerns i kind of
have with the zone it's because the
section is very much a blessing i think
it's also
it could create future issues i'm
surprised at this point it hasn't
created future issues because
um
one it doesn't have a very
well-described system for how school
districts would apply to keep their
current election system as established
in their bylaws and articles of
agreement or as adopted per rsa 195
colon 22
in rsa 671 colon 9 which this
legislation also addresses so there's
not really a specific system i know that
you know the board chair after the word
votes would petition to the department
of education but there's no real
explanation of the scope of what and you
know what kind of parameters the board
of education would use it'd be very
subjective based on kind of essentially
the current governor's administration
and who they've put on there or previous
administrations and what kind of their
um their goals are on the board of
education
my second concern is this recourse is
allowing school districts to keep their
election systems preserved which is
great you know my school district would
probably you know be one of the first to
to um to apply for such a uh for such a
um you know preservation but it also
could be a loophole used to undermine
cooperative school districts um vote to
for reapportionment so you could have a
school district that could reapportion
and this language basically would allow
a school district to petition you know
let's say someone put in a petition
warrant to reinportion the districts and
all the voters approved it well
theoretically now a school board after
that reinforcement can say
well actually the voters made a mistake
we're going to go to the department of
um sorry to the board of education get a
change
it also could mean that even if you pass
this you know some of the issues that
we're trying to address like for example
in the school district that represent
moffett is from his school board could
go to the um to the board of education
and say
you know the state legislature made a
mistake i mean you may end up having 40
plus cooperative school districts that
are going to go all basically nullify
what the legislature just did or at this
point now it's kind of being brought to
light i think they could nullify a
petition warren which i think is the
best way to address this kind of concern
an issue if your school board isn't
properly addressing it if you live in a
community with either disproportionate
representation where you feel your
community isn't getting a proper voice
on your school board
um the fourth kind of one i know i said
only had three but i actually have four
is we also have the issue that will
depend on unelected state board to make
these decisions rather than voters and
districts and that's my biggest concern
of kind of those four
listed concerns regarding that section
is how it currently works is the voters
are the ones who make the ultimate
approval over this election system and
how they're going to elect the board and
how it's ultimately going to operate
because how you elect your board is very
determinative of what kind of culture
your school district has your
cooperative school district and if
you're going to see all this power to
state legislators which will turn into a
partisan issue all of a sudden if we're
going to seat it to an unelected board i
don't think that does it justice to our
constituents at least not my
constituents in the governor wentworth
regional school district
i'm also on page two on lines 9-13 i
appreciate the amendment giving
cooperative school districts some
control over the transition process this
was a huge concern that the school
boards association brought up in the
previous bill house bill 1646 and
allowing for this transition process is
you know let's say um it's a good part
of of this kind of solution um and this
new section does give school districts
the ability to prepare if the amendment
actually becomes law because that was a
huge issue too i mean at least we'll get
five years rather than being thrown
right into it having to solve it on our
own now my other issue though is the
fact that each school board is going to
have to create its own plan without a
lot of guidance
right it's kind of tough i mean our
school board has elected this our board
members the same way since we
established a district in 1963.
prior to this you know much of the state
statute even existing right and then the
state statute came about we already you
know by chance used one of the election
systems as described in rsa 195 colon
19-a but it would be a huge change for
our district and you know also the um
our founding documents for this district
to completely change our election system
overnight without any approval from our
voters without any kind of um you know
concerns i've never heard a concern
brought up in my community about how
we've elected our board members
i didn't even know that it was much of a
concern elsewhere until house bill 1646
came across
my eyes the last bit of change
proposed to this section of rsa is on
lines 19-23 it makes sense to apply this
requirement if we plan on ensuring every
cooperative school district has proper
proportional representation if you know
that's the ultimate goal of the bill and
even if that's not possible for some
cooperative school districts in this
proposed system which i think there are
some districts that quite frankly they
wouldn't be able to have proper
proportional representation if this went
into law
um now just kind of three i have a few
comments on that you know after walking
through the bill is um my first thing is
i'm a little bit confused as to why
we're taking away the power and the
flexibility of cooperative school
districts to choose their
apportionment and have voters approve
proposed reapportionments to me it seems
undemocratic and antithetical to the
local control that we pride in the state
of new hampshire rather than allowing
voters and cooperative school districts
to make these choices we'll have state
lawmakers most of whom are not from
cooperative school districts make the
choice for communities like mine
cooperative school districts and their
voters will probably forever lose their
control over reapportionment which to me
has never been something the state of
new hampshire likes to do is to take
away this kind of power from communities
i think there's also um my concern also
is the fact that we change the rules for
over 40 cooperative school districts
when no school board has officially
taken a stance of the need to have the
state law change no cooperative school
board has asked the state to do this
i very like i said i've never heard
anyone in wolfeboro my district ever
complain about how this uh current
system
works
um and even more there already is
recourse which is probably why school
boards have never gone to the state
right in the state law as you know i
just kind of you know explained is if
you want to put in a petition warrant or
your school would want to make the
change or your school board wants to go
to the to the um board of education
you can make those changes
um
i think kind of the the last thing too
and i took down some notes based on what
people had said was um
we have to remember too each board
is distinctly different some school
districts right like to have an entire
district elect board members because the
board should advocate for the entire
district as you know the honorable
lovejoy representative lombjoy mentioned
for example in our governor wentworth
regional school district board i have to
sign a document every year affirming the
ethics policy the ethics policy is very
explicit i can't speak for the board i
can't speak you know before we kind of
make a decision on something or you know
try to do things unilaterally even more
when i do anything on the board or the
board acts we have to act as a whole and
for the entire community i can't act on
behalf of wolfeboro i'm an at-large
member but even still i couldn't say you
know even if i was the member from
wolfeboro the member from effingham or
the member from brookfield it's very
clear in our ethics policy which is
binding which can get you censored or
even removed from the board for
violating if you're trying to act on
behalf of just one community
right the board has a whole process of
how they kind of you know maybe do an
investigation decide what they're going
to do with the member who is violating
the ethics policy which has 15 points
which is on our um our school district's
website so i have a fear that um by
making it so then our school district
can no longer have one at-large district
that elects all our members that we
would end up creating more sectionalism
which is already a huge issue that we
have in our school district is trying to
make it so that people are more unified
going in one direction rather than
pitting towns against each other because
we're trying we have one common goal
we're trying to improve public education
for every student who goes to the
governor wentworth regional school
district who chooses that's the best
path for you know themselves
i think the other thing to remember too
is we shouldn't eliminate at-large
members from communities for example as
mentioned by a previous speaker he
talked about the governor wentworth
regional school district um currently
wolfeboro despite having three at-large
members on our governor wentworth
regional school district we only have
two seats right two residents of
wolfeboro in seats one in an at-large
seat one in a wolfeboro seat
if this was adopted and if we couldn't
get any recourse from the board of
education would end up happening with
our three at-large seats is
essentially two of them would just go to
wolfeboro and one of them would go to
ossipee the two biggest towns so the
bill actually in many ways this
amendment i should say
would have the exact opposite effect on
our community it would end up giving
wolfeboro a guaranteed disproportionate
voice in ossipee too so theoretically if
the three wolfeboro members and the two
ospie members the biggest towns at any
time decide to change anything they
would out rule the other
four towns which to me is concerning i
don't i don't want that to happen in my
school district which is why this kind
of issue is such a um
it's not a sensitive issue but it's a
complex issue there's a lot of working
parts when you have 40 different
cooperative school boards
it's kind of tough to create a
one-size-fits-all solution that's going
to actually address the culture and the
needs of every cooperative school
district
um i think that's
it for all my notes
but i would be more than thank you very
much are there any questions for
representatives
yes representative nelson
thank you mr chairman having been in
that small town living in the small town
brookfield where there are only 800
people
which are you say you were my shoes and
you had 800 people in your town
do you think and let's make believe
they're all one party or the other you
know they're very conservative town or a
very liberal town in their views should
they be able to have a say at a school
board meeting that represents their town
you mean the town of brookfield should
they have let's make that one in town to
grow people yeah they do they have uh
do all people get to vote on that like
the people who may be in a very liberal
all the other towns are liberal or
conservative should they pick
brookfield's representative
the way that we voted in our school
district that's what the voters wanted
when they first started the school
district in 1963. follow up mr chairman
yes you think that's fair i mean if i
was somebody that was very let's say
liberal or whatever word you want to use
should the other towns that are very
conservative block me from ever saying
anything because they're all one
well i thought should i be able to speak
something and give my opinion because i
represented little tiny brookfield well
i actually in many ways i agree with the
core tenants and philosophically with
what you're saying i just have an issue
with the state being the main arbitrator
of such and taking away that voice from
the voters um and i can understand the
concern though that you know what would
happen if you put a petition warrant in
a town like you know let's say a larger
town like wolfeboro without rule the
other towns that i mean that's that is a
legitimate concern but i think again
in a democracy in when when we elect and
when we make decisions on petition
warrants it's it's on us the burdens on
us people who feel maybe like the way
that you and i feel represented nelson
to go to the voters and to explain why
this system's better for our school
district now i'm not entirely sure that
system would be the best way for our
school district to go forward um i
wouldn't oppose though a position
weren't being put in and you know i
would have to really look at it and say
is this going to be what's best for our
school district
thank you
representative uh des we know that
there's a number of cooperatives out
there 30 32 of them
that have not looked at their agreements
in many many years
some dating back to
1963 64 some even going further back
but the apportionment issue
do you agree that in this bill on the
very bottom section there 20 through 24
on page two is needed where every 10
years apportionment would be looked at
based upon the census
of the the us census
rather than just continuing as is based
upon what happened back in 1960 when
demographics were different
the
the economic power of these various
communities has changed significantly
and that's another issue which is
in the co-op districts is this uh you
know apportionment based upon
adm is it based upon total census is it
based upon some combination of with
the assessment values of in those
particular communities
so do we need to have
a good healthy look at and do you
support this aspect the bottom several
lines there of this bill where we'd have
to apportion every 10 years based upon
census results yeah
you know and like i said i think that
makes perfect sense with the bill's
ultimate and trying to make things
proportional i
you know and i think even um
you know i wouldn't i certainly wouldn't
be opposed i think it's good language i
mean i mentioned you know that language
would 100 be necessary for this bill to
work i think it'd be good just in
general i think districts should be
looking at this more often i think it
makes more than enough sense that you
know a district being forced to look at
this to put it to the voters and to have
the voters reaffirm it and the voters
don't then obviously a board says well
we have an issue if people aren't happy
with our election system as it currently
is um i think the only the only thing
though is whether or not you would need
to require it also for school districts
that elect their members at large
because technically they're properly
reapportioned
right so i mean that could be something
that you could go into and say that
every district has to look at it whether
or not they have an at-large
district you know even districts sorry
even school boards
even saus operating with one at-large
district that also need to reapportion
even though technically we're properly
reapportioned i mean that's part of the
benefit in a rural district where it's
kind of tough to make sure everyone's
vote is equal is when it's one at-large
district i know my vote counts the same
as anyone else's vote from any community
no matter the size right it's one vote
one vote when i vote for school board i
vote for what's going to be best not for
wolfeboro but what's going to be best
for all six towns and for the entire
school district and what's going to
serve mostly i think about what's going
to serve taxpayers best you know in all
six towns so you know i think sometimes
it's kind of tough to always assume that
every person casting a vote is casting
it just because
they have a specific interest for their
town but i definitely agree with you
though mr chairman i think looking at
this every at least 10 years and
requesting school districts reapportion
and even more you know
having school districts update these
kinds of agreements right especially in
the case you know that we keep pointing
out of representative moffat school
district where that doesn't seem fair at
all to me that one town has more than 40
percent of the population but only 18
percent of the voice on a school board
which i think that's kind of the
the biggest thing that this bill should
address or this amendment is making sure
that every single
vote is equal to every single other one
when casting a ballot in a cooperative
school district
i think that matters a lot
thank you
representative luna
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much representative duchess for uh
uh joining us this morning um
uh just to your your your prior comment
with regards to
the um the
reapportionment language in um in
section three of the uh the amendment um
if that were to apply to existing
the the existing four methods
listed in roman one two three and four
on page one uh that that reapportionment
part
would would apply to roman two in roman
three is that correct because those
don't require at large voting
and continue
with what you were saying
if you're voting out large yeah i know i
i agree with you but i think what the
what the chairman was kind of alluding
to is the fact that forcing school
districts that do elect at large to kind
of take a close look at it if it's
really serving what's best for their
cooperative and their voters which i
think is a i think that's more than a
fair way to kind of look at it and to i
think it's more than fair to you know
for school boards to appeal to their
voters again especially considering for
example i mentioned my school district
hasn't updated its voting system since
we established in 1963.
i think it's more than i'm going to
interject here for a second because what
chairman lab was driving at okay is that
current law says
you may apportion you may
there's no oversight and requirement
that every 10 years you shall apportion
and that's my concern that there could
be a larger district that's satisfied
the way things are but there's other
districts which are growing
and there's
a disregard for taking on that topic of
apportioning because somebody's going to
lose votes
so
it's a complicated thing yeah thank you
for thank you for clarifying and i would
agree with that and to follow up on that
uh mr chair so uh so to representative
nelson's concern
um would uh would another option you
know out of existing law be viable
to uh to ensure that uh that um that may
be a small town that may be politically
different than than other member towns
of the of the co-op
um
has a has a vote like for instance would
would roman 3 under the current options
um
possibly
um satisfy his concern
yeah i mean i i think i think the way
that the law was originally written to
my understanding
i believe this section of 195 is either
from the 90s or it's from earlier in the
early 70s kind of right around the time
when a lot of these cooperative school
districts like mine were being created
but kind of the idea of what the four
systems currently established
are was to give
school districts i mean this is a lot of
latitude these four kinds of systems are
you know broadly they're kind of the
four main ways that most um
municipalities are kind of electing
members of across you know new england
and everything so i i think there's a
whole bunch of flexibility in the
current statute um but i that's not to
say that i don't hear the concerns that
are brought up by folks and by you know
the people bringing forward this
amendment it's just to say who should be
the ultimate arbitrator
of
making the choice between these three
different um these three different
styles of apportionment i've always felt
it pretty strongly
that it should be the voters who elected
the members of the boards and the voters
who are the ones who live in that
district who pay the taxes there that it
should be ultimately them and you know
it's just one of those things where i
know i may have upset some people and
kick the bees nest and you know kind of
bring this up and kind of even
testifying here but it's something i
feel very strongly about so great thank
you very much thank you very much
representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um when these cooperative school
districts were first formed and they
were actually uh state sponsored at that
time to try to make school districts in
like
effing effingham be a little bit more
efficient uh
by combining towns together um
that they were trying to keep um
the feeling of and i think you talked
about culture and community the local
culture and community that is inherent
in our um school system whether it's a
community or whether it's a cooperative
district and so in a in a community uh
of a school district whether it's a
separate town like if wolfeboro was its
own town
wouldn't that town have
sections of the town that would be
conservative and sections of the town
that might be liberal and that joining
together as the local education
association or as a as the elected
school board don't they represent
both those factions and so
the cooperative districts aren't they
just a
larger
reflection of that
well i can i can speak to my board i
know my board has republicans democrats
and undeclared voters on it but when we
ultimately look at
you know when i say republicans it is
plural i'm not the only republican on
that board i know that for a fact but um
when when we look at um
when we look at these issues i mean i
can't bring my partisanship into it
i have to look objectively of what's
best for the school district so i i see
you're kind of what your question is is
is it not true that whether it's one
town or you know multiple towns that
there's interest you know partisan
interest that people have that reflect
national issues or state issues that
they project on some of the local school
issues i mean that's true and they're
members of the board who also kind of
bring up those concerns too but i think
ultimately especially in our school
district we try to distance ourselves
from that to try to make it so then
these these kinds of issues that we're
talking about with public education are
less partisan and that every member of
the board and the more abort as a whole
could be more approachable right i mean
that's kind of our ultimate goal but i
think the biggest thing that you touched
upon though that it's important is um
the cooperative school districts and how
big of a benefit they are to big and
small towns right being able to pull
resources for example i wouldn't be able
to take ap classes and college classes
if it wasn't for the cooperative school
district because we wouldn't have enough
students to run those classes and be
able to take those tests and everything
so that's a huge benefit of why the
governor of the regional school district
was you know able to really set me up
for success and to give choice right and
a whole host of electives that i was
able to take because we have more
students and more resources but um even
more
um
[Music]
the the point is that we're one
community and we don't want to be six
different towns that just so happen to
be pooling resources together fighting
over all those resources are used we
want to be one community working
together to keep improving public
education in that area making it a
viable option for every family
thank you representative woodcock
thank you chairman i'm not sure if this
is for representative de shays or for
you um welcome back to the chance thank
you uh i was going back to your comment
rather than land on the section 20
line two
page two 21 through 24
and comparing it to what i heard
represent the shade asking for if i
understand this correctly and
it may not be correct i'm asking if i
understand this correctly when you get
down the line 21
and 22
that says that it will be reapportioned
it will be reapportioned after every
census
so that that would eliminate the
at-large
option is that correct
depends upon if you're referencing back
to statute as it is right now
um as statute is right now
just prior to the
added part you're looking at the
sentence above it says
may
re you know and that may is something
which
i would have to go back and look it's
very difficult to look at all these 30
co-ops and get a hold of them some of
them it's i don't even know if you can
find the darn agreements
but have they reapportioned
i
i i can't venture but i would say
there's some that really haven't
in fact some we we got craziness out
there in terms of membership in these
co-ops my district has two two districts
within it but they're not school
districts one is a precinct
within the town that so
and there's a lot of dynamics to why
that occurred
this could be taken care of if every 10
years you had to look at this issue
in regard to everything that preceded it
on page one that's been wiped out or
whatever or whatever's going to be there
uh i i think it's a good idea that we do
have some overarching oversight that you
will look at this
co-ops every 10 years because there's no
guarantee that they're going to do it
especially if it's controlled by one or
two
districts within that co-op to have the
votes
and the bottom line in all this is not
always the well-being of student it's
what's coming out of my pocketbook
and and and the economics and the
assessed property values etc so i i
think we're looking at a huge topic here
that's very complex probably the best
bill we ever had here was to get rid of
maul
and and start from scratch and
representative cordelli presented that
earlier and of course we nixed that
uh so just clever okay go ahead
wherever that represent life yeah
clarification but with the striking of
may
uh and the inclusion of the way 20
through 22 is written
it
basically says it will reapportion
there's no more me it's not an option
you will
be reapportioned it doesn't have to be
every 10 years would be less frequently
but
you will at least every 10 years
reapportion so if you reapportion that
means that would eliminate by
understanding correctly that would
eliminate any at large options
shall review it to apportion means are
we going to go ahead and go ahead with
change i get that change may not be
necessary
on line 21
the fourth word from the end it says and
reapportioned if necessary based upon
the sensitivity okay that yeah that's
and of course
that means law if necessary is not there
i know but that's in the amendment we're
talking about so back to my point that
means that'll be gone right
well i think we're getting into what we
should be doing in executive session
here
we have somebody at the table
do you mind if i answer your question
not me i have to go through the chairman
i think i think what we'll do is we'll
we'll address that yeah when we get to
exactly i don't know if it's i don't
know if it's really because you're
asking boards like i could imagine my
board would review it revise an update
but our review revised an update with an
at-large district might just be well we
reviewed we still have an at-large
district and everything is properly
apportioned there's nothing to really
revise and there's no update you know so
i mean i guess it kind of depends on how
you might construe it i can see how
you're looking at it but how i think my
board would look at it would be
we feel as if it works and we'd you know
resubmit it i don't know if we'd have to
put it to the voters but i assume maybe
but i think that's fine thank you um are
there any other questions for
representative shea we do have one more
pink card here to go through
representative litchfield
thank you thank you for taking my
question i have a part a and a part b um
it sounds like your board does work very
well together i'm just curious
how long have you been on the board how
many board meetings have you been to
so i've been to now two board meetings i
previously served as a student member
for an entire year i've watched the
meetings for about three years straight
whether it was on youtube or in person
um i formally i mean you know my
girlfriend's mother was a chair of the
board for 10 years i've been with my
girlfriend for seven um
so i'm just gonna stop so well i'm just
saying i have a lot of familiarity with
our board
yeah um
i love you my dad's a doctor i can't
deliver a baby but he could
um do you support the electoral college
yeah
do you feel this is any different
yes i do okay i don't think we're on the
topic of this right now we're on
cooperative school boards there's a lot
of dynamics in the governance of our
country yeah
that
and that it's
we don't want to go there
so further further questions uh
representative
yeah there's two questions here
tanner
um i guess my my question is uh and it
kind of goes to
your longevity on the school board is
that you know i i was a in a cooperative
i taught in a cooperative district for
35 years
and they did
have periodic times when they reviewed
the contract when they reviewed the
apportionment
and i'm just wondering you know it's
kind of
what i'm hearing today
is kind of they don't do it
and um you know your short span on the
school board obviously you haven't had
the opportunity to be through that but i
would be very curious
uh
to take a survey of all the cooperative
school districts in the state
and find out
if in fact they did
look at their their um
reapportionment along with their
cooperative agreement um and i think
most boards probably do at certain times
look at that as a as that arises in the
community but
as you i think you
and just to make sure you did say that
there is a process right now
for boards to for the cooperative school
boards to petition right the state
there's three processes to change your
reapportionment one is for the board to
put it on a ballot one is a petition
warrant and one is to go to the board of
education which i even realized until
this amendment came out that it was even
part of the law that you could go a
school board could go to the board of
education
and ask for a change too
thanks i think that that's an important
emphasis
okay uh last question representatives
so it seems that
you approve and it sounds like a lot of
the people here approve of setting up
school districts school boards
cooperative school boards like a house
of representatives
and it looks like merrimack has decided
to set theirs up like a senate
and i'm wondering do you have an
objection to that i mean do you see that
as a as a viable
i have an objection if it was my
district but i really support every
community making their own decision in
that way because they
merrimack valley school district know
what's best for the merrimack valley
school district the governor wentworth
regional school district knows what's
best for it the exeter cooperative knows
what's best for the exeter cooperative i
think at the end of the day the dynamics
are so complex between these towns these
agreements are pre-existing and it took
a while to create these agreements and
it's ongoing and they constantly they
can change or sometimes they don't
change because it's better to stay
static but with these kinds of complex
dynamics it's hard for us
in this room and for 400 legislators to
understand the dynamics of every
cooperative school district and what's
going to bring about the best results
for those cooperative school districts
and how they elect their members
thank you thank you very much uh with
that uh thank you for coming today and
we'll ask uh bear christina from the
school boards association to come
forward this is our our last pink card
yeah
uh good morning chairman lag and morning
members of the committee bear christina
school boards association pardon my
voice i'm on the the back end of a cold
and uh i've had laryngitis the last
couple of days
um i'm trying to try and be brief i know
we've been on this um uh amendment for
i'm moving and close to an hour and a
half two hours now um i'm not gonna
spend a lot of time um we are opposed to
the amendment um a lot of the reasons
why i've already been mentioned by
representative des and miss lovejoy um
before him
um i think a couple of the things that i
will want to highlight though some of
the broader base policy concerns
current law allows for four or five
options for a community to select
methods for a community to select their
cooperative school board members as i
read this amendment there's it's down to
one
we're limiting voter choice we're
limiting options
for voters to decide how they want to
elect their local officials on our local
cooperative school board the second
aspect that i would like to make is that
we have not heard that this is the
problem statewide we've heard from one
maybe two
individuals in particular co-ops who
don't like the current method within
their community
nobody from merrimack valley has come to
complain about it nobody from conval has
come to complain about it nobody from
governor wentworth has come to complain
about it so i don't understand why we're
spending this much time making this
drastic of a change limiting voter
choice for something that may be a
concern
with a couple people here and there and
in one particular co-op there are other
methods within the law that can address
some of the challenges that have been
addressed so my question would be rather
than
going through a legislative process that
we how many hours have we spent on this
both the original bill this bill
and the
the imaginations that
that occur on the house floor
you know my question would be rather
than changing legislative process that
impacts
32 school districts how many knows how
many kids across the state
was there a petitioned warrant article
locally to change the method that's
currently allowed in law
was that did we go through that process
first to see if that would have
alleviated some of the concerns
um
so you know we're going from five or six
choice whatever four or five choices to
as i read it one
um
so i i just i don't understand
why that why i don't understand why this
is such a a a concern
for this body when we are not hearing
these concerns statewide
um
the other aspect you know uh page two
again the the mechanics of how this is
going to work when some school board
members are going to have their seats
eliminated presumably
page 2 lines 9 through 12 by july 21st
2025 so i don't understand what happens
to the person that gets elected to a
three-year seat in march of 2024
they have a three-year seat they're
going to be on the board for
four months and then suddenly we're
changing the process
and if we think that
communities are going to be able to
agree to whatever process comes out
locally um i think we're i think we're
being naive um the lawyers that
represent school districts probably love
page 2 line 9 through 13. um the rest of
us probably are not going to
um another sort of logistical challenge
that i don't think is addressed in the
bill
um
i'm this is a this is current language
in in in while i'm on the first page
sort of the introductory paragraph
the number composition method selection
terms of cooperative school board shelby
is provided in the bylaws
or the articles of agreement of the
cooperative school district okay so we
know that the method for which your
school board members are elected are
contained within the articles of
agreement
as the case may be provided however such
bylaws and articles of agreement shall
be limited to the following and it's
then it lists out the proposed amendment
bylaws and articles of agreement within
cooperative school districts can only be
changed by a vote of the body
by a warrant article
so what happens then if this bill passes
and then we go to annual meetings
of march 23 year 24 to somehow implement
a new provision with this and the voters
reject it
they don't they vote not to change the
articles of agreement we've got articles
of agreement that are in conflict with
current law and i don't know how to
rectify that short of coming it back to
to the voters again or perhaps the state
board of steps in and then we get back
to the issue of whether or not we want
unelected bureaucrats
at the state level dictating how local
elections are going to occur in our
local communities
nhsba does not think that's a
that's a that's a prudent proposition
so um
with that i think those are the primary
concerns nhsba has again um i i do want
to thank everybody that's worked on this
i understand it's it's an important
issue for some people and um the report
that representative abrami put together
presumably with perhaps some other
people on this committee if there's an
extra copy of that floating around i'd
like i'd like to be able to have a copy
of um just so i could i could take a
look at that i knew you know the time
and effort to do that um must have been
significant so we certainly appreciate
that and
respect um you know the work that's done
on this to address
the perceived concern
but nhsba opposes opposes the amendment
as we did with the original bill um
happy to answer any questions
thank you very much are there questions
of the school boards association
yes representative woodcock
thank you chairman thank you uh i will
take my question uh in terms of the
uh review
uh it's been
mentioned here multiple times
do does your association uh notify
the cooperative school districts in live
saying don't forget to do this annually
or buy annually whatever it is to remind
the people to do that
thank you for the question
um representative no i don't think i've
had occasion to do that i don't think
i've ever been asked to do that um only
um in the situations in which a
cooperative school district
is reviewing the totality of their
articles of agreement
which is allowed under law um
and you know more times than not that's
sort of a precursor to one of the
communities looking to potentially
withdraw or at least study withdrawal
thank you thank you chairman
you're welcome
representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um
i think it was the first year i was on
the education committee uh jim grenier
was a representative from
goshen lobster area and served on the
school board and that was a massive uh
disturbance of a cooperative district
and and it seemed to me that
that there was some issue about the
the league legality of a cooperative
district in the buildings that they
owned
that for example if there was a building
in leimster
when they split up and it was part of
the cooperative district goshen still
had uh
some sort of stake in that that
particular building it was owned by the
district which was considered
like a municipality in itself
um could you just
am i remembering that correctly sure
thank you for the question um
representative
um correct representative jim grenier
from lemster served on this committee
for
eight years maybe representative if i
recall correctly
um and back and i believe was 2016 or 17
there was a study commission
chaired by representative grenier to
look at the withdrawal process
at the time representative grenier um or
at some point concurrently
representative grenier was also a school
board member in the goshen lobster
cooperative school district
um they split i forgot who initiated i
believe it was lobster i could be
mistaken one of the challenges um with
that particular withdrawal was that
leemster had the facility goshen does
not goshen does not operate any schools
so there were questions as to um
there are always questions upon
withdrawal over who has to pay for what
who retains what property
um you know usually if the building is
within your town or community
you you retain it
um
excuse me one of the other challenges um
as i recall with that
cooperative school district withdrawal
was um
they weren't quite sure if the co-op
remained as an entity
um so if you let's say you have a three
town co-op if one town decides to
withdraw you still have a corporate
entity of the two remaining towns right
because this was just two towns and they
split
the question was does the cooperative
school district still carry on as a
legal formal entity
um cooperative by its nature seems to
imply more than one so can you have a
cooperative school district that is only
one district i forgot how that got
resolved to some degree it was more
academic than anything else
um you know related to that and you know
representative chairman lad and i've had
some conversations about nhsba's
recommendation again is that we have a
two-year-long study commission to study
the the totality of rsa 195. we need
lawyers in we need people from the dra
to talk about proportionment we may need
somebody relative from from like the
attorney general's office or the
secretary of state to talk about sort of
the one man one vote and the
proportionality of things of that nature
um this sort of patchwork approach does
not work to a system that is getting um
where their frustration is increasing
across the state in certain segments of
the community
trying to cram everything in and fix
this with this committee respectfully
you've got a lot of other work is a
challenge in in and of itself
i hope that answered your question
representative so just to be clear you
would recommend that we we have instead
of little bills or bills like this maybe
not little but bills like this
that we actually have a commission a
study committee that
my recommendation would be a two-year
study commission because this cannot be
done in a single year it's way too
complex we bring in the lawyers that
know the historical aspects and have
worked with cooperative school districts
for 30 or 40 years at no apportionment
we bring in again dra to talk about that
we bring in some cooperative school
board members we bring in some
superintendents members of this
committee and we and we look at
wholesale changes to rsa 195.
thank you because we do have two other
bills
that we as an education committee have
put into interim study uh about
cooperative districts thank you
thank you very much
yes when jim did take over that
subcommittee that i asked him to do
we did get a report but it did not
resolve all the itch in fact i'm in a
co-op with just one town in the co-op
right
um and everybody's elected at large
uh it's just you know there it's a mess
but i do have one question for you here
pardon me
well
jim did a good job because he was
dealing with in the districts with one
or two and there were there was some
resolution but not going there with it
uh in regard to this last portion on
this bill
is there a need
that we have something in law which says
reapportionment member uh
reapportionment of
members of the cooperative school board
you could say
in in relation to the pre-existing
district shall be reviewed revised and
updated etc etc
um that's not occurring in all these
districts right now i know that's not
happening correct and it does need to
occur
and and would would doing this in
conjunction with that 10-year
federal census give us the data points
in order to accomplish this yeah thank
you very much uh chairman ladd um nhsba
doesn't have any specific objection to
that provision
that is certainly probably a best
practice that they should be looking at
their at their population numbers every
10 years um the one
aspect that we need to be mindful of and
to some degree i think representative de
shays brought this up
um
reapportionment of members of the
cooperative school board shall be
reviewed and revised the updated
you know does up does updated imply that
there has to be a change made because
what if they review it at the 10 years
and say we think we're okay or we're
we're in accordance with the numbers
currently so but looking at the numbers
every 10 years somehow tying that back
in yeah i think that's reasonable yeah
not ann but maybe an hour or something
something like that yeah thank you yeah
further questions
thank you very much thank you very much
not seeing any more pink cards we are
done this particular hearing
and i don't have my gavel but we're done
um what we're going to do now is that
we're going to take a short break
for folks to you know visit the the
facilities down the hallway but also
we're going to have a short caucus as
well
uh
we have six bills which we're going to
have to exact
later this morning and we're running out
of morning
uh so how much time
representative milor would you need for
a caucus
you're good okay
okay we're going to need about 20
minutes
yeah so we'll come back at uh 20 minutes
after 11. thank you very much
okay ready to start here we're in
executive session now and the first bill
we are going to take up is sb 353
so turn to 353
relative to the education
professional standards board
and
i'm going to hand the gavel over to
um
reps and cordelli so a motion can be
made
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
yes i call on uh chairman ladd for a
motion i move ought to pass
on 353 relative of the education
professional standards board
second anyone
resemble
thank you okay
i'd like to uh propose an amendment to
the the 353.
that amendment is
uh
1755h
i'll second that
discussion on the amendment
uh yes a very brief uh discussion here
uh the this changes the membership of
the professional standards board uh to
include those that you see there uh
including at least two classroom
teachers who reside in new hampshire at
least two education specialists who
reside in new hampshire
and at least two instructional
specialists who reside in new hampshire
that's in part b this remembers came to
us
when we had department come before us
uh requesting the initial changes on 353
and and the second portion of the
changes are nine members employed by a
new hampshire community college state
university community college system of
new hampshire or the university system
of new hampshire including at least
three full-time teaching faculty and
three higher education administrators
representative anything no i think that
covers it very well thank you
any further discussion from the
committee
uh seeing none
maybe we could do a uh hand vote
oh
okay
uh hand vote
clerk
yes please a hand oh
are you voting yeah okay all those in
favor of the amendment
yep
thank you 19-0
okay um
i'll take it from here yeah um so we
have uh 353 on the floor and further
discussion i rep uh recognize represent
cardelli thank you i would like to uh
move out to pass
on amendment
h
is there a second
represent bone seconds the amendment on
amendment 1675 discussion representative
cordelli
uh thank you i think we had a rather
long discussion uh just a little while
ago on it um but uh i i think it is uh
important to proceed
to make some progress
with cooperative school districts
it does not affect funding which has
been a large
issue that i think will take further
work uh but it does i think address
uh membership um and inequities there
um
and you know we've heard uh testimony
from the school boards association that
there's frustrations increasing around
the state so i think that this will
help in that regard thank you
further discussion representatives
i am i just sent down an amendment to
the amendment
which just adds a second after the a
a new b that says by a vote of the
people in the district to confirm the
agreement they already have
and then the b changed to c
and so if we could wait to vote on this
until
the end
of the other bills that would give us a
chance to get that back could you read
your language one more time for me
please
for the b
i'll have to find the exact language
um
hang on let me go to my dre and my scent
i said
the new bee which says confirm a newbie
says
confirmed by a vote of the voters in the
co-op district to confirm
uh
sorry confirm the current agreement
one more time please yeah well hopefully
they will catch the fact that i
put in two confirms
confirmed by a vote of the voters in the
co-op district to confirm the current
agreement
there should have been a comma in there
and there wasn't but
okay
is is there any discussion yes
representative bowm
use your mic please
i thought i hit it but it didn't take
what they've done your main amendment
the issue i see in some cooperative
school districts where you may have a
big school
and a lot of smaller towns around the
school districts around it
and if every everything is like in
somewhere
everybody's at large
all it would take
is somebody just to campaign in the big
school district they wouldn't even have
to campaign in their own
so
i think you should live and
be voted on by the people that
you want to represent in your school
district in the cooperative school
district and not everybody vote for you
a good example of that for example is
what's bad is the new hampshire senate
district we just came out with
litchfield is
combined with five awards in manchester
no way
that representative so it's the same
type of thing where
the people in one in the small town
should have
their with who they want not who the
whole district wants
thank you
represent mullen
thank you mr chair so what about the
towns that are going to lose votes
because in uh representative abrami's
example
uh i think it was the merrimack valley
school district
there were a couple of towns that were
actually going to lose votes they
currently have two school board members
and they're that now going to have one
school board member i would like to know
how many school districts does this
apply to
how many cooperative districts does this
apply to what the heck kind of response
are we going to get from dis
from towns that are losing clout in this
uh in this reapportionment i uh
i i feel like i was
i'm quite surprised at the ought to pass
motion quite frankly because i felt like
we heard
compelling testimony to study this
not to impetuously act upon it but to
study it after listening to
all of the concerns that uh
i i did not hear the school boards
association say that this was a swell
idea and that we ought to move forward i
heard them say that we needed to study
it uh
so i i'm i'm very concerned about the
towns
that are going to lose their school
board votes
could i respond
represent cardelli uh yes i i didn't
indicate that they said it was a swell
idea i said that the quote was
frustrations are increasing across the
state
with cooperative schools
representative miller
thank you mr chairman
you know we just spent almost two hours
talking about the complexity of this
issue
and those of us that have been on this
committee before understand
the dilemma here
and rather i i like the impetuousness of
uh
ms mullins uh representing mullen's
comments because that's exactly what
this is
we already have set up
to study two other comm two other issues
regarding co-op districts
this to me should be part of that
we're talking about eliminating
uh three different options
to one option
that doesn't seem to be proof to me as
we begin to look at this issue
we've not heard we've only heard one
issue around this
as far as the need for this we didn't
hear we don't hear any compelling need
for this at this point in time from
around the around the state so why would
we be acting on it now
we need to have further input from those
co-op co-op districts representatives
from them not just from one area
i i really would encourage this
committee to at least defeat the otp on
this and at least throw it into an
interim study if that's what you want to
do but right now it's it's very
important to do it at this point in time
thank you
further discussion
are we going
from
to one option or two options we i see an
a and a b
the b is
if you want to continue with your
current situation you may
ask the state board for approval to do
so
so is that
likened to a second option
that may incorporate those other options
uh that's a question out to the
committee
uh represent like us
i was just gonna say my amendment gives
the third option which is confirm the
current agreement by a vote of the
voters in the co-op district
thank you
i believe when we were
working on this
looking at providing
four options that was the intent of b
is to use the same process of going
through the state board that was the
intent of of b
represent boom
just to remind people we already voted
19 to nothing on the similar bill that
was tabled on the house floor so
i don't know why we have the
disagreements now thank you
represent woodcock and represent luna
thank you chairman
um
i would go back to
item b and i have a different uh take on
it than the representative cordelli
where it is an option where it says it
may be approved by the state board of
education i have two thoughts one why
should they have to apply if
everything's working fine but secondly
what happened to the state board of
education and says no we have seen times
and other pieces of legislation where
one person's
philosophy overtakes a whole group
this this concerns me that we have
schools that have to go and ask can we
continue to do what we do
that we do well and happily and the
state boy said nope we want you all to
do this
so i don't see this as an option at all
when you when you give the provision
they may say no as well as may say yes
thank you
representative
thank you very much mr chair yeah i
think um referring back to the um the
the bill that was uh that was introduced
on this subject and and subsequently
tabled on the house floor i don't think
a 19-0 committee vote naturally reflects
um
the um i think the substantial work and
substantial testimony we heard this
morning
as i recall and i don't have that bill
in front of me uh we only heard from mr
christina on that bill and it may have
been late in the day after uh after a
number of bills and i don't think that
we had the type of robust discussion and
testimony and questioning that uh that
we had um uh this morning so uh so i
know that uh uh if i knew not if i knew
then what i know now i would not have uh
been one of the 19 people who um who
voted for that bill and i suspect others
may may feel that they're in that
um same ballpark too but i think the the
testimony today
uh representing
um i think uh uh certainly a broad
uh
group of uh of of of people i mean um uh
former member patty lovejoy said she was
representing herself but uh but in fact
she is involved with uh with election
law
representative des serves on a school
board um a co-op school board uh used as
one of the examples today
and um and then i think um barrett
christina representing the school board
associate association which many times
do not um take a position on these bills
but i think he took a very strong
position uh for the school board
association on this one largely because
uh there's been no complaints um filed
with the school boards association based
on any need to um to change this law and
uh and at least in a in a quick review
of the couple of dozen
school board association resolutions
that they have online none are related
to um to this issue so so um uh so you
know so i think for for at least those
reasons
um this uh this could be looked at as is
really sort of jumping the gun and i
think the unintended consequences
of
of rushing through legislation such as
if in a in a co-op district one of the
one of the towns has a population of 93
and they get one board member and
there's 6 000 population in the district
then you've got a board of 60 people
or 65 people on that on that school
board um if you want to comply with the
with this law there's just there's
there's too many of those
sorts of
sorts of unintended questions
that i think could be answered if we uh
if we instead moved forward with what mr
christina recommended which is a
two-year study commission uh listening
to lawyers superintendents school board
members members of the public and others
associated uh with with hopefully
helping to
to to
identify problems and find
resolutions that are workable thank you
further discussion
we have some districts
that have multiple multiple districts
within the co-op
and there is a limitation you can have
no more than 15 members on a cooperative
school board it's odd numbers starting
at three and working up through
if you have a very large large district
that's three times the size of the other
six or seven
how
my question is and i guess it's to
represent cordelia or
how how do we assure that the
the apportionment is based upon
you're going to have every district
having one
and then you're going to have a few left
over which in the past been either at
large or or you know
haven't been assigned that way
how how do you assure the larger town
town a
[Music]
of that's the
lion's share of people they're going to
get a proportion number of of members on
the board based upon population
i think that
with the examples um from representative
abrami he showed that in that
the population
would
determine the apportionment and
a larger district
such as in in one of my districts uh
wolf bro would have uh possibly three
members um
and uh
goes down from there two and one for the
rest of the towns
right now instead they have three at
large members but
predominantly they're from wolfeboro or
ossipee the two larger towns because
everyone votes for them so i don't think
that that's proportional either
so i'm looking at the in the
governor wentworth school district right
now
and there's three at large
if you're going to and there's
five six seven eight nine nine on it
earlier
you could enlarge that
that by your articles of agreement to
15 if you wanted to
has there been any thought given to that
in terms of looking at the wentworth
this school district here governor
wentworth
that if you did that
would wolfeboro then wolfeboro i would
assume
would get you know several more uh folks
on the board
that's possible but at least they would
be
elected from wolfeboro
um as opposed to having um brookfield
and effingham uh representatives get
elected by
wolfeboro in effect also
no
yeah representatives
yeah i don't think it mandates at all
that there are 65 board members because
it said apportionment shall provide
flexibility
to the cooperative school district in
meeting requirements of one person one
vote doctrine
so you're saying everybody gets at least
one
but it doesn't say then from that one we
have to be fully proportional it says
apportionment shall provide flexibility
which means then you use common sense
you can't have more than 15 how do we
apportion the rest so i don't i think
that was a
straw man argument
further discussion represent tanner
thank you um i have a few comments i'd
like to make one is uh you know i
i
worked in kearsarge it's a cooperative
district i've spoken about it many many
times probably too many times but
they're against
this kind of you know jolt to their
system
um
we had
in our in our in our testimony back and
forth we had a lot of uh things that
weren't answered because they were
hypotheticals
and
i think hypotheticals can easily equal
unintended consequences and i think
there's many that are
fraught in this bill
i think
we need to have a study of how many
cooperative districts are dissatisfied
with what they have
you know why have a bill
for just one
one cooperative district
that's having issues
and i think that
[Music]
you know we're in the throes of
redistricting right now
and
the people that worked on the
redistricting committee if you talk to
them about
reapportionment and the different
uh
parameters and data that they had to
work with in order to come up with
whatever they had and even though they
did that they still have these in
particularly in rural areas where rural
areas are where cooperative school
districts are probably more prevalent
but in rural areas even for the house
they came up with floatarials again you
know and i'm part of a flotarial i
represent eight towns
and some of those towns are pretty big
and some of those towns are pretty small
and everybody votes for me in those you
know those eight towns so
um and i guess the last thing is that
the little little plug about those the
commissioners
um
it that's in the senate now and it's
been stuffed into interim study so
that's that's not even an issue uh that
we should
be should have even been talking about
here
so
i guess
the final word from me would be that i
would vote for interim study i would
vote that this
this can go to a study committee as it
should a commission like the school
boards
uh
christina suggested i think that's
that's the way to look at cooperative
districts i think to throw something
like this in a wrench in
um
particularly when i think my feeling is
the majority of cooperative districts
are moving along
they're supporting their children in the
in the in the school district uh and in
the various towns they're forming their
own culture and and community it's local
control
and um
you know for us to to make a
one-size-fits-all here at the
at the state level uh and put our foot
right on local control again i think it
isn't necessary so i'll be voting no on
this
further discussion from the committee
yes
thank you mr chair
i'm representative lane and i'm a sub so
i feel a little out of place maybe
commenting but
i listen pretty hard to what was said
and
i'm also a lawyer and i think the
gentleman from the new hampshire school
board association
reminded everyone that there are a lot
of legal issues here and there are a lot
and i would particularly point to the
language in
lines 20 to 23
on page two of the amendment
because they're problematic and they
require reapportionment for all the
options not just for option a but for
all the options and if you have
something that is not based
if you have at large you are requiring
reapportionment and that's what the
language says and we're not amending it
um
i also am on the redistricting committee
and i echo what representative tanner
said about the difficulties that you
face when you're doing this
i'm also concerned that we're throwing
out the one-person one-vote theory
and i haven't heard anything that says
we need to act on this now that this is
so important that it has to be done now
so why don't we take the time to study
it and do it right because we can do it
better i think we heard issues we're not
saying that those issues aren't
important we're just saying
one size does not feel fit all and new
hampshire is known for local control and
i think we should be
honest to that goal
thank you
further discussion from the committee
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take about a five minute caucus here
about five minutes
for me
yeah that that's a that's probably a
good idea
well
no we we the other bills but no we have
this well we could
pick this up later
uh but um what time do you have to be
able to do a couple of others
yeah
how about if we recess this one right
now and we'll go on to several the other
well we can't get all the bills done
anyways because the amendments aren't
done yet
they're coming back so let me pick a
couple of these bills we might be able
to zing right through
um
let's look at uh sb 238 relative special
education services in charter public
schools
okay 238 is relative to special
education services in charter public
schools going to hand the gavel over to
representative cordelli
uh thank you mr chairman uh call on
representative vlad for a motion i'd
like to move ought to pass on 238
and is there a second
representative baum
uh discussion do you have uh something
further i believe
yes i'd like to offer amendment
h
i'll second that
uh discussion on the amendment
the amendment deals with and recognizes
the need for an mou but i think that the
the amendment also
captures the rationale and reasoning
behind it a charter public school and a
school district of residence for one or
more students of the charter public
schools shall enter into a mou to ensure
compliance with state and federal law
for providing special education services
that's in in the bill
and it goes on and it keeps part b
uh the the department shall develop
that's unchanged but unc prior to the
start of a school year the charter
public school and the school district
shall review and update the mou to
ensure compliance with state and federal
law and responsibilities to provide
services in accordance with
individualized education plans it takes
away the
the time frame of two weeks
it says prior to the school year and i
think it takes some of this
this uh um the specifics that we had
there with the uh two week period of
time
and and makes it more realistic what's
going to actually happen
and so i'd like to support and and um
see 238
amended as such with 1765h
nothing further down on that thank you
any uh
discussion from the committee
i've seen nuns
um madame third maybe we can do a hand
vote
sure hand vote on amendment 1765-h
please
19-0
uh is there a
further
motion
representative
yeah i'd like to make a motion ought to
pass as amended with 1765. this is
talking about 238 represent lunaro i'll
second
that motion i have no further discussion
any further discussion
scene none um matter clerk
okay representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lakers yes represent
moffett yes represent hobson
yes representative ford yes
saudi yes representative nelson
roseanne miler
yes
representative luno
representative sullivan yes
representative tiener yes representative
ellison yes from zamboan yes
representative woodcock yeah
representative lane
yes
yes representative hall yes
chairman ladd yes
okay so the autopass is amended um
passes 19-0
thank you consent okay with everybody
good great uh next bill will be sb 421
sb 421 and relative dual and concurrent
enrollment for career and technical
education center students
once again i will hand the gavel over to
representative cordelli
thank you call on representative vlad
for a motion i'd like to move out to
pass on 421
is there a second
correct
representative hobson
okay who made that motion
excuse
okay okay
um
any discussion on the amendment
no we haven't gotten there yet oh i'm
sorry okay
so further further amendment okay
uh yes a discussion on 421 i like to
move amendment 1758 h
and also
yeah i'll second that
thank you
a discussion on the amendment yes we had
uh
some discuss we heard in testimony on
this bill this is the bill that deals
with concurrent dual enrollment where
through working with the community
college system in new hampshire
students can enroll while taking a
course
either at the premises of the college or
at the
the residence school
and there's certain conditions which
they must meet in order to do that
that's spelled out in the national
alliance for
concurrent enrollment partnerships
that they would receive 150 dollars uh
support from the state which we
appropriate each year but they'd be now
working directly with the community
college system on
there was question whether this would be
available to students in the private
school
and then there was concerns about is the
student that's attending this private
school from the state of new hampshire a
resident of new hampshire or a resident
of florida attending that private school
it could be holderness it could be
kimball union academy it could be any of
those fine schools which we have in the
state
and the concerns were raised that there
needs to be an amendment for this so
that the award of the 150 is for a
student who resides in our state
but may attend non-public school public
high schools and that the non-public
school has looked for you know and
entered into a policy statement
allowing this to occur um so the
language in the amendment does all that
and the language has basically been
submitted to us now by the community
college system new hampshire
school board of each school district and
governing body of each institution in
the case of a non-residential non-public
school which opt to participate shall
develop and adopt a policy permitting
students residing in the district or in
attendance at the non-public school who
are in grades 10 11 and 12.
so
this i think takes care of many of those
issues which we were discussing earlier
when we heard the bill
thank you representative luno anything
nothing further uh thank you
uh thank you uh committee any discussion
on the amendment representative woodcock
thank you
chairman cordelia president ladd this is
just a question for my own edification
if a
student in one of those academies that
you just spoke of
is allowed into this community college
program
uh does that school pay the fee
and what the what is that fee
i would have to
you know go to shannon on that because
or beth they're both here for the
community college system
and you know if you want the technical
response from them if you would love
that please sure
ms reed
thank you mr chairman um
no representative woodcock that in that
instance the the program that's
established to fund these courses would
pay for that this amendment limits the
limits the
students are eligible however to
new hampshire students who are
in either of public schools or in the
non-public non-residential
schools
so
um
the
state program that appropriates the
funding for the
to basically pay the students tuition
would would pay for those courses does
that answer your question
i think so follow up
yeah thank you so in representative
ladd's example of a youngster from
florida who attends the resident
non-public school
would they be allowed to attend this um
the amendment the amended language does
not include that student
um it for two reasons one the student is
not a new hampshire resident but two
this amendment online uh let's see line
seven
line eleven line seventeen talks about
non-public and non-residential the
intent was to capture those schools that
are kind of normally part of uh new
hampshire's high school ecosystem like
the the trinity and the bishop brady and
that sort of thing but differentiate
those from the schools that are really
kind of
kind of separate unto themselves but
those boarding school environments that
really haven't ever been part of this
program and and we wouldn't imagine that
there'd be
um much call for them to become part of
the program thank you thank you chairman
any further questions comments
thank you miss reed
anything further from the committee seen
nothing
we'll do a uh hand vote for the uh
for the uh amendment
looks to be unanimous
uh uh
representative do you have further
motion yes i like two
moves sb 420 or
421 ought to pass as amended with 1758
h any second to that representative luna
second that thank you
discussion
scene none madam clerk whenever you're
ready
okay this is senate bill 421 with
amended um as amended autopass 1758h
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield yes
representative boehm yes representative
lakers yes representative moffat
yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
represent milor yes from san bluno yes
representative sullivan yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison yes from sam mullen yes
represent woodcock
resembling yes represent paul yes
chairman ladd yes okay it carries 19-0
consent okay with everybody great
back to you mr chairman yeah thank you
okay where are we out here
we're jumping around here
no there were like i hear you over there
[Music]
yeah i think we're gonna have to take a
break right here
so we'll take a break here and you can
have take your lunch too and we'll try
to get back here by quarter of
yeah is a half hour too short
use the elevator
okay you're welcome
thank you
so we're now back to uh 353 as
previously amended
and
i'll give you the gavel
thank you for the gavel and uh uh in
return i'll ask you for uh a um motion
yes uh thank you i'd like to move 353
[Music]
and senate bill 353
with the amendment that we i'm looking
for it i think um 17 17 55 h yep
ought to pass as amended
no second that thank you
any further discussion from the
committee
on the ought to pass his amended motion
scene none
madam clerk
okay representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative blakis yes
represent moffitt yes
represent hobson
oh she's gone just kidding
uh representative milor yes
roseanne luno yes representative
sullivan yes representative tanner yes
representative ellison
represent mullin yes
represent woodcock yeah
represent blaine yes reset hall
yes
chairman ladd yes so the auto pass is
amended um passes 18-0
okay consent i guess uh it's okay with
everybody
great
that goes this way
that way
next bill we have uh senate bill
requiring student identification cards
to include the national suicide
prevention lifeline and i'd like to
invite mr mrs dickey up to the table in
front of us
thank you
we have an amendment here which i think
we're all very very proud of and we
haven't introduced it yet and but we
wanted you to be a part of this
um and remembrance of your son
and um
jason can
you know
i hope he could hear me right now by
saying that
this act that we're going to pass today
and this amendment
will certainly support and assess so
many students
k through 12 and throughout high school
in the post-secondary careers and i want
to thank you very much for coming today
and sitting through all the stuff we the
mess we went through this morning early
er but um you're both so appreciated and
we thank you
so um we have
amendment in front of us and this is not
an amendment
this is a kind of an unusual amendment
the way we're doing it
it's not sponsored by any specific
legislator it's sponsored by the entire
committee
so with that i'd like to
uh move
senate bill 234 ought to pass
is there a second representative miler
yeah
me
thank you
so i'd like to offer now amendment 1801
h
for uh amending to senate bill 234
this act shall be known as the jason
dickey suicide prevention act
that's my motion
and
and represent representative miler
seconds that
i guess there's you know i can read this
so that it's it's very succinct and in
short but very much to the topic
and then when i did some research on
this over the last several days i went
to the national suicide prevention
as listed on and i understand they have
a new telephone number too 988 that's
fantastic
um and also i went and also looked at
some of these cards which are being used
already elsewhere in the nation at somo
states which is also something that
hopefully our state will be on top of
very shortly here
but the act reads short titled this act
shall be known as the jason dickey
suicide prevention act
and what we've been mended the bill by
saying the national suicide prevention
lifeline shall be labeled on student
identification cards and include the
telephone number national suicide
prevention lifeline
nine 1-800-273-8255 eight
further discussion from the committee
this is unusual too for the discussion
from you all
we just like to say thank you to all of
you for considering this and we're
humbled and honored and if jason could
hear it he would absolutely feel the
same way i'm sure he was verily very
politically oriented and he would be so
humbled by something like this and
speaking on behalf of our family we are
as well thank you thank you very much
we're proud of you as well
represent mullen did you have your hand
up
not seeing any further discussion
madam clerk would you uh call no that
this would be a show of hands on the
amendment
all those in favor of 234 as amended are
the amendment 1801 h
thank you that's unanimous
now the um the bill itself senate bill
an act
which is now going to be called the
jason's dickey suicide prevention act
amendment to ought to pass as amended
with 1801h
ought to pass his amendment with
amendment
any further discussion
yes represent milor
okay thank you
any further discussion from any
committee members
madam clark clerk would you please call
the roll
i'm shaking i think i'm gonna have
trouble calling it without crying
thank you
representative cordelli yes represent
litchfield is yes representative boehm
yes
representative lakes yes
represent moffat yes
i'm sam hobson yes
representative ford
yes sam soti yes
representative miler yes i'm just have
luno yes representative sullivan yes
representative tanner yes representative
allison yes
sam mullen yes
represent woodcock
representative lane yes represent hall
yes
and chairman ladd yes
so this motion carries 18 to zero
can consent from
okay great we will
no not not on consent no we're going to
have this done by the entire hall so we
won't put it on consent
rick yes question can you place this on
on consent i mean
special order
uh so that we can deal with this when it
comes out early in the session
yes we can we can special order right to
the top
and that we will do with the speaker
yeah absolutely thank you very much for
the suggestion
it's been very few times that i've had
correspondence from governors saying we
support a bill such as this i had it
from john lynch i've had it for me
hassan
and and now i have a letter here from
johnson
from chris sununu
and so this is very important for the
state of new hampshire and once again
thank you for coming
and
i know this will
be a great asset to so many families
throughout the state so thanks again
thank you
okay
let's see 238
um
353 is done
board
410 and 352 are left
so let's do sb 410
for tennis uh act relative to the public
comment periods of school district
meetings and meetings of the state board
of education
i look to representative moffat for a
motion
uh sure mr i like to move
otp subject to amendment
okay
we need a
second
representative litchfield seconds that
uh represent moffitt do you care to
discuss your motion of ought to pass
famous show i know that there's an
amendment that is in play as well i'll
speak to the
my motion on the
original bill is simply to say that
during
the hearing we heard a lot
a lot from
numerous people who are concerned about
voices being heard
and
in this measure would
address that somewhat
and and require uh
periods for public comment
represent litchfield do you have any
comments
i agree 100
okay are there
do we have an amendment on this bill
um yes represent cordell you're
recognized
thank you i would like to uh offer uh
amendment
uh
1320h to
senate bill 410
is there a second
well second
who said that
representative litchfield beat you to it
so representing litchfield second set
represent cordelia care to speak to your
motion uh thank you
um
the main
uh goal of this
amendment is to make sure that
people can be heard
on agenda items as well as non-agenda
items
i think too often
common periods are provided by the board
at the end of the school board meeting
so that parents don't have the
ability to comment on
discussions and actions that might be
taking place during the meeting by the
school board
so
the amendment
says that
comment periods shall be provided for
public input
for the agenda items
before board action is taken
and she'll also be provided for
non-agenda items
we had discussion about i think the
30-minute provision
um in the bill as it came over from the
senate
uh so i added that
public comment should be no less than 30
minutes unless comp
comments are completed earlier than that
so you don't have to you know wait 30
minutes you know if only one person or
no people are speaking
during that period
so i hope that addresses that situation
further discussion from the second
no thank you
open to the committee represent milor uh
thank you mr chairman
uh this uh
kind of falls into the line when we talk
about do we need to
legislate local issues
there's no question in my mind of the
need to have
public comment
the need to have input from parents and
from citizens
dealing with issues facing school boards
but
this is a local issue
this is clearly
in the design of the prerogative of
local
school districts and school boards
to create the policies
and the process for that input to take
place i don't believe that we need to at
the state level
to begin mandating
what needs to be done at a school board
meeting this is their responsibility
if people are upset with how it happens
they can elect vote them out of office
with their vote and so i don't think
it's appropriate for us to be making
this kind of a
mandate from a legislative standpoint
thank you
further discussion representatives
clearly leaving it up to the school
boards has not worked
we have seen lots of
[Music]
issues
where school boards did not have public
comment or restricted people
to just the agenda items and would not
put on the agenda things that
townspeople were concerned about
and consequently
parents have become very upset and very
distrustful of school boards
and
that is not a situation we want to have
what would be much better is just say
give a public comment period
everybody has their say and then
i think people i think
um
members of the district will be much
less likely to get upset and
some of the things we've heard about
shouting and various other things going
on
if they're just heard
further discussion representative
woodcock
thank you chairman um
the just to
clarify or at least uh
think about what the president like has
just said this amendment doesn't
allow public comment
uh verbatim it allows public comment for
items that are already on he was talking
about there's talk about the amendment
says
um lines 13 14 and 15 for action it's
already on the agenda it doesn't talk
but that wasn't that wasn't my point um
this is for reverend cordelia he did the
motion of the
amendment my question is if i want to
make sure i'm reading this correctly or
perhaps incorrectly
um it identifies public comment period
the third minute 30 minutes or i think
you said less plan so it doesn't if it
doesn't finish
but then it says
provided for
agenda items before board action is
taken
a and then again
before
non-agenda items so does that mean
that
since there's seven or eight items on a
school board agenda
right so if i read that if i want to
play the flip side that means after each
before each item is voted i have a
public comment period because this says
before board action is taken
up on agenda items so
it seems to me that that could be
read
to
that may not be your intent it seems to
me it could be ready to say well this
says i did before board action is taken
so the board individually votes on each
action
and so we stop
would do dialogues then they have public
comment then action then the another
something comes up board public comments
in action is that is that can that be
read this way or am i reading it wrong
uh uh how about i'm talking to
representative cordelli cordell yes
thank you um i i do not believe that is
the case i i think that um
a public comment period
um at the beginning or somewhere before
um
uh
gen items are discussed
um
would satisfy this provision
if the board wanted to
have
a public comment before an agenda item i
would think that that would certainly be
within their purview for instance if you
were
talking about several things um proven
minutes so forth
and then had a
discussion period on um
new bus routes or something i think it
would be totally uh appropriate um and
uh in line with this amendment to have a
comment period specifically for that
agenda item uh but uh
i don't believe that uh it should be
read that uh public comment before each
agenda item is required
mary paul that's true yes jeremy thank
you
so does
i understand what you're glad i
understand the intent of what you're
saying i think the intent is accurate
i'm just still reading it as that is it
seems to me this may be quiet we
may be required
uh so we do the the bus route thing but
now the next thing is on uh uh
athletic athletic participation the
third thing is on the lunch new price of
the lunches so after each thing
that i hear
are you saying that we're going to start
the
board meeting after we get two minutes
if you have public comment on any of
this stuff that make it now
but i read that to say is as
provided before each board action so
there should be dialogue before the the
transportation there should be dialogue
before the athletic participation there
should be dialogue before the meal price
increase
um i just i just that's just how i read
it
represent cordelia you want to respond
um it says public infor input for agenda
items it does not
say republican for input for each agenda
item
the same thing happens
yeah follow up and thank you
representative i apologize thank you for
interrupting me the same thing says it
shall be for the non-agenda items so it
just seems to me that that's each
individual item as a line
i understand you're good your intent is
valid i just think this could make a
real massacre of a school boy meeting
representatives
i agree with representative cordelie if
they want if he wanted it to be what you
say it would say for each agenda item
before board action is taken instead it
says
agenda items so we can talk about all of
the agenda items before and you could
think of it as any board action is taken
so it's not
it's not on a particular item it's any
board action so before any of the agenda
items
are acted on by the board there can be
public input and that's basically what
it says and then the end shall also be
provided for non-agenda items
that's why it has
multiple
comment sections because the school
board could say oh we only had a couple
comments on
agenda items so people want non-agenda
items you can do it now or if there's a
lot of comment on agenda items the
non-agenda items don't need to be
commented on before the agenda items
right
so at the end
that would be the second comment section
at the end and then any non-agenda items
could be brought up then so it's left
flexible
so that the school board can figure out
based on who shows up and what they want
to talk about
what order how they're going to do it
but i can't see that it could be
you would have to have written each
agenda item
for each board action to to do what
you're trying to do
trying to say
represent tanner
uh thank you i i have uh
two things one is
that
under what representative lake has just
said
if we had
four agenda items on the school board
let's say the bus schedule the athletic
eligibility and the price of meals
under this to have just one comments
period you would have to
have each one of those items talked
about and then at the end of the board
meeting
uh action taken and and the normal way
procedure goes into school boards that
i've been is that they discuss something
like athletic eligibility
and then they vote on it and it so then
action is taken so
if
if i'm reading this right it says before
action is taken
so if action is taken on the bus route
then there's got to be a comment section
and then if action's taken on the
athletic eligibility there has to be a
comment section and then if the price of
lunch
they take action on that then a comment
period has to happen before they take
action
um
so that's
that's what i and the other question i
had was there was it seems like the
state school board is missing in this
like um
amendment and also
when we uh had discussion on this in the
first place there was some comment that
um
we should include charter schools also
because
um
a lot of not a lot but there was some um
information
about charter schools not having a
public comment not not not being heard
um so
i'm just
wanted to know why school boards were
taken out of this the state school board
action and also
how i see this is written
the english language is sometimes uh
very difficult to you know read through
but on line 12
where it says public comment period
shall be
would it make more
would it be easier to really understand
if i said ah a public comment period
shall be provided for public input for
agenda items
and so by taking and putting the word a
in front and and taking the s off
periods
um
and then on line 14
each public comment period
i know that my board meets as a comment
at the beginning and at the end of the
meeting there's two
and but many only have the one
either front or the back
um
would it be wise take the each out a
public comment period shall be
and and take the each which connotates
maybe that there's going to be each for
each agenda item
um so that i i guess that would be my
catch on this right here which would
clean it up you know
making those maybe those three changes
representative thank you mr chair for
taking my um my comment slash question
if you're going to do that on line 13
where it says
provided for public input for agenda
items before board action is taken
and shall also be provided for
non-agenda items that to me sounds like
two periods of time one would be the
comment period for agenda items and the
and shall be provided a
meaning a comment period for non-agenda
items so
um i i just bring that to your attention
because i think we're talking about
two two comment periods there
or just to include or something
republican period
represent lucas
yeah but
if nobody shows up for the
agenda items and everybody can and the
people who came just came for non-agenda
items you don't want to
you want to let them go ahead and speak
in that first
time
right so you don't want to be specifying
what can be spoken in
you know the public ones
the agenda item ones get take spoken
before any agenda item actions are taken
and the other ones can be
wherever it fits in
you don't want to be specifying they
have to wait till the end when nobody
shows up for the first one
represent woodcock yeah i get um this
chair and the bigger picture i i i would
have to
as we continue to look at this playing
with local school board agendas and how
it's
developed and who can speak when
um i i have to agree with with
uh representative milo this this is out
of our daily way let local school boards
set their own agenda and if people don't
like it they won't elect them if they
want to speak they won't elect them
that's why the local school boys that
that's the meat of it we're just we're
trying to tell a local board what to put
when how long someone can speak and if
it's if it's an agenda item or not a
gender item i just think we're going way
out of bounds on this one now
represent boom and then wrap something
often thank you mr chairman as a former
member of the school board we had
comments before and after and they're
open the thing is we've seen over this
past year
in some districts school boards have
been
deliberately not taking comments
deliberately going about getting people
arrested
deliberately only doing their comments
at the end
and at midnight you can make your
comments and that's what school boards
have been doing
so
the answer to what was said yes school
boards can do what they want now and
unfortunately they're overstepping their
bounds to not listening to the people
and waiting for a year for a next
election or in some cases maybe two or
three years that's not good enough we
need school boards start doing their
jobs like when i was on the school board
and stop being
elitist and saying what we think is
what's best for everybody we need the
public comments be given thank you
further discussion
yes
um i'm going to put my lawyer hat on if
you're going to
amend it in line 13
to me the problematic language is before
board action is taken
that that implies i think what
representative woocock was was alluding
to and spoke on so if you're going to
change it to a public comment period you
still have the issue of before board
action is taken if you've got five items
that have to have action on them the way
i would read that is that you need to
have that public public comment period
before the action is taken on that
agenda item
and i know that's not the intent but
that's how it's written
so
the way most are doing it right now
there is a public comment period at the
very beginning of the meeting so that
would be prior to taking action on any
particular item on that docket
follow-up yes um then i would suggest
that you say before the meeting begins
or before the before the you know i
don't know if there's a formal term for
this school but before the meeting
begins
or before the item agenda before the
meeting agenda
you know is addressed i i don't know but
i i've never been on a school board so i
i've attended but i've never been on a
school board so i would defer to the
people who have been on a school board
and know
when do you start doing the agenda items
and how would you say that
in place of those four or five words
they're all listed well they're all done
differently many of them are following
robert's rules
and you like new business old business
etc and underneath old business you
might have something following up that's
come from previous
but then in a new business you would
have a litany of those one through six
or seven items that are on the dock for
that evening sometimes a whole lot more
than that
so the board meeting starts when the
gavel goes down
and
do your roll call and all that
everybody's here and you're you're on
with it and you you recognize guests if
you haven't but then you get into the
meat of things when you get the old
business
maybe you could say before the um agenda
items are addressed
as simple as that i don't know
well there's a lot of things on the
agenda
that are non-action type things
that you know you just might have an
informational item on there which you're
not taking action on imparting to them
we're having open house on
christmas break as such and such you
know
yeah you approve your minutes of the
previous meeting etc
i think the wording that is here there
there's room for maybe a few tweaks to
ensure that we're not talking multiple
comment periods like i know when i was
on other boards like a zoning board or a
planning board you would have a hearing
prior to taking action on a new zoning
request and you'd open that up to a
butters etc
so you would then have you know multiple
comment periods
uh within that that whole
agenda that evening or morning
so open up for comments represent
woodcock
thank you just a question to further
muddy this up
in cities in cities when they're doing
budget actions
the school annual school budget the
school board sits there and goes over
different line items and votes budget
often by line items
and cities not small towns in cities so
does that mean every time before they
have a budget vote on a line item
i was on city council yeah for nine
years school budget and and so but city
council is a larger entity we would have
ordinances which would come up and each
ordinance would have its own hearing and
you'd have a first reading a second
reading and then you really we often
took action on the third reading but on
the school board budget there's hundreds
of the line items that they vote on yeah
yeah
yeah represent mullen
thank you mr chair i just want to draw
attention uh to the fact that unlike
representative bowman my experience in
the
beautiful bedroom community of bedford
new hampshire is that the public comment
period this year
for most of the year went for three
hours before the meeting began the
meeting would begin at seven and i kid
you not because i was either there or
watching that that public comment
section would go on and on and on
because if hundreds of people show up
um
you know then it's up to the board how
they want to handle it so i think that
the that it's not true that all boards
all school boards are shutting people
down because that certainly is not
happening in my community
i want to draw attention to removing the
state board of education from the
requirement of uh the 30-minute public
comment i i would like to object to that
because i would like to see the state
board of education be as open to public
input and as
welcoming to comments as uh we believe
our school board should be
so i would um i would object to removing
that i think they ought to have a
30-minute public comment period as well
represent cordelia uh i think we heard
from the chair of the state board
quite well about
the state board
trying to provide for public comment and
very often have had very long
public comment
periods as you described in bedford as
well
further representative moffatt
thank you miss chair i just wanted to
quickly respond to uh representative
woodcut and representative miller
with regard to
us
looking
down
at
involving ourselves with school local
school boards and i certainly are a
local control person and i think most
school boards are fine i really do to
include bedford's and litchfields and
but here's the thing um
clearly if you're at the hearing there
are some onerous a few onerous
situations with certain school boards
where people are not being heard and
that is very troubling and it's our role
in our responsibility in my view
uh to
pay attention to that it's similar to
like for example on the federal level
sometimes in the south historically
there were local
school boards or school districts or
states or whatever who did not do what
they should the right thing
and the people had no recourse locally
because the the locals in the the south
if i can say that
it's historic uh needed a higher level
of intervention involvement to make the
right thing happen so on a more micro
level that's how i see this there's a
need for us to pay attention to people
who are asking for help to be heard and
i think that this does that
is your definition of south everything
below the massachusetts line uh
mason dixon i hate to go there but uh
don't go there please
thanks
are we beyond going beyond the arguments
on the or the debate on the differences
between
the amendment and
410 as it was amended in the senate and
came to us
because i think you know from what i'm
hearing a lot of the a lot of the
argument now
applies both to the amendment and to the
uh the underlying bill if
is that correct
well i i heard representative mullen
make reference to the state board of
education which is minus on the
amendment right and so i think she was
speaking to the amendment saying why you
know i can't support it because
right but
i'm speaking about what say
representative moffatt was just saying
which i think applies both to the
amendment and to the underlying bill
i'll let representative moff you know
respond but i i think we're uh speaking
to the amendment right now correct yes
we are right and my promise was simply
uh in response to some concerns that
were
getting involved with local control my
point was sometimes we need to
and that's speaking to to their
response to the amendment
sir further comment or discussion
okay we do have a amendment on the floor
right now
it's amendment 1320h
is there any further discussion on that
amendment
all right um
madam clerk would you please um
and then i'd like to see a show of hands
or not a show of hands on this let's
have a roll call on this please
this is on amendment 1328 to set up bill
1410 president of cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm representative
lakers ghost
represent moffitt
representative hobson yes
representative ford yes
representative soti yes
represent milor no
no no
representative sullivan no
president tanner no
representative ellison no
represent mullen no represent woodcock
representative lane no representative
paul no
and representative excuse me chairman
cordelie
hmm
last name lad oh my god that's okay
your father's a doctor i skipped once
yes yes
so i was like i was thinking oh my god
he doesn't know his vote what's up
yeah nine to nine wait the motion's nine
to nine and emotion fails
all right now we're on the
that's the way it works
uh
now we're on the
main bill itself now which would be
sb410
rick further discussion yes thank thank
you very much mr chair um i'd like to
speak uh uh in support of um of 410
um my and for just a couple of reasons
first of all that that i think it does
address the um uh the the point that
representative mullin was making with
respect to the state board of education
and um
understand during the pandemic there was
there was a lack of
of
comment during state board meetings i
think we heard from the from the chair
about some maybe technical reasons why
they did that but somehow school boards
across the state worked through those
technical issues and were able to to
take public comment
secondly my understanding is that the
senate this morning
did
did recommend
passage of
house bill 1195 which i think origin uh
did that origin no that was in that was
not in this committee originally
uh
uh and um and now it reads uh like uh
410 as it as it came to us
and um
and uh uh i believe that was a committee
amendment from uh from the house
education committee so um so i'm gonna
i'm gonna support for
as it as it has come to us
i think on voice vote and five nothing
out of the senate education committee
further discussion
representative lekkas
so i have a question
for those who did not vote for the last
amendment
it seems like part of the issue was the
state board of education
not being in here
my question if we did a real quick
amendment that just said
that all we changed was the public
comment period shall be for no less than
on line seven
at the beginning
and that way
the concern that the public session is
at the end and people had comments they
wanted to make
about agenda items and the agenda items
are voted on and then they consider
their comment
void or or you know no point in making
it you guys have already made the thing
would you vote for this if we just put
put the at the beginning in there so
that it could be done
before the agenda items were voted on
well i'll speak up on on the
i have a concern with a any kind of a
comment period that's designated by
x number of minutes no less than 30
minutes
i like the other
amendment because it said
unless comments are completed earlier
so you might you know if you're the
state board and their meetings go clear
to two o'clock three o'clock in the
afternoon at times and if you have to
spend 30 minutes opening it up and
waiting for a public comment period
there's nobody there to come you still
are in public comment
and so it's going to be wasted time
downtime in that case could we instead
just add the whole section
to new section that talks about the
state board of education
on to
the amendment that we just voted on and
that way
we would have that language cleared up
as far as when
and then also
put the state board of education in
there would people support that
just looking for options
i i don't know if we have time to do it
right now um
even though there were some real simple
fixes i thought to the cordelia
amendment
which would have clarified
you know that we're talking about a
public comment period instead of public
comment
public comment periods
uh
so
i don't know i think we just gotta act
on it now i don't think we have the time
uh whether we pass or not
excuse me
back to your original wording i wonder
if you just added the phrase if
requested
and lead if it wasn't requested then
they could terminate
it puts it
it puts the responsibility on the person
wanting to discuss it to request the
opportunity one thing we've got to be
aware of and very cautious in doing is
that
when we make these quick fixes
in our committee right here
20 minutes later if you're you know
when i was working with dr ranzuli down
uconn on the gift of town and stuff a
lot of people don't really engage on a
topic until 20 minutes after they get
involved into the topic itself and we
oftentimes make the
change right now and then live to pay
the the price later on when in fact
somebody's trying to make it work
so if we don't have a
a real good response right now
i think the best thing is just don't
mess with it and
leave it be
further comment
yes uh to your point mr chair uh about
the uh
the time
the notion of people sitting around for
30 minutes on line 10 it does say
nothing in this section shall restrict
school boards from establishing
uh reasonable standards for public
comment so i think i think that's a
little bit of an elastic clause that
would
you know i and i i just have to think
that board chairs
could uh
if there's nobody there
right i i think that
i wouldn't worry too much about that 30
minute deal
i just wanted to address the
i agree with what you just said um and
regarding the local control just because
i've sat on the board for so long
especially during what had been
happening over the past two years
the boards actually were hungry to hear
something come down from the state level
and whether it was masking or you know
remote or whatever they were so
frustrated saying they did not give us
direction
and one thing that i've noticed over the
years with public comment i'm one that
always
had it at the beginning and at the end
and there were many times people in the
office of superintendent that would sit
with me because we would develop the
agenda together and they would say but
you don't even have to have it at all
right and typically
they would revert me back to the new
hampshire school board association and
that is where everybody goes with these
boards right you pay your dues that's
where you go to see what you should or
should not be doing
which is a lobbying organization people
don't necessarily go to the doe so i
understand what you're saying about not
getting in the weeds but i think that um
sometimes we're not able to get out in
front of people and educate them of the
importance of this or that they can go
beyond what the new hampshire school
board association is recommending i've
heard that quite often so i just wanted
to share for whatever reason this
doesn't make it today
i just hope that moving forward you take
that into consideration thank you
representative
um i'm still concerned about when it
happens
that's all i'd still like to see it in
the beginning because i know how upset
uh numerous parents were at certain
school board meetings because things
were voted on before they got a chance
to say it and say anything about the
things that were voted on
and
you know that that can be very
frustrating
does anybody know how this came out of
the senate what kind of vote was on the
senate was it
was
i was just looking at it's a voice vote
on the floor it was 5-0 out of committee
5-0 and unanimous on the floor correct
thank you
any further discussion
madam clerk
colin rule
this is the motion of ought to pass on
senate bill 410
representative cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lakers yes represent
moffitt yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes
representative soti yes
representative miller yes
from san bluno yes
representative sullivan yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison yes represent
mullen yes
represent woodcock yeah moffitt i think
representative lane yes representative
hall yes and chairman ladd yes
so the autopath carries 18 to zero
and uh consent okay
representative moffat i think you made
that motion
right roger that committee report
roger that
okay one left 352.
okay 352 relative to substitute teacher
criminal history records checks
okay represent cordelia is there a
motion
yes thank you miss chair i'd like to
move on to pass and i have an amendment
represent
second
representative cordell you're recognized
for
discussion
uh or a motion yes i would like to uh
excuse me offer amendment uh 1697 h
and speak to my motion when
okay okay second on that okay
go ahead speak to your motion thank you
amendment um
this amendment to uh 352 i think um
does everybody have a copy of that
um
refines and narrows the scope um in
terms of
um
ferpa exceptions
that's in section d
um lines 20 to 27.
um
it narrows it to
disclosure of information to a
contractor consultant volunteer
or other party that is acting instead of
internal
services within the district
and requires notification to parents in
those instances
which was the specific instance
which
led me to uh draft an amendment in the
first place
um
it also addresses uh who the
notification shall be provided to and i
think covers uh all parties
um uh attached i think or you should
have um the actual statute that i
referred to
um in um
in the amendment in relation to uh
to ferpa
could you please explain to me how
last last time we discussed this there
was some concern about a school district
submitting information to the department
um
how how's this
amendment impact that process
uh thank you
um it is uh only in the instance um that
notification will be required when it's
disclosed to a contractor consultant
volunteer
or other party uh to whom the agency has
outsourced services or functions
so
and if you look at the
attachment
it clearly does not
cover
any part of the department of education
how does that impact the uh
the
child that's been referred to family
youth services
by a teacher that's governed by law that
has to do this
does do they have to follow that up with
a 10-day later communication
no the uh school district is not
outsourcing uh services or functions to
that replacing um the contractor or
agency in this in that case is not um
acting instead of um district personnel
are there
representative mullen thank you mr chair
um this is a question for representative
cordelli uh could you give me some uh
like real-time examples of when a school
district might disclose information as
they contracted with somebody
um in the in the situation uh i
discussed
um
uh earlier
uh they are uh contracting with a third
party
um and it it's
required as part of that contract um
that uh
uh district personnel enter
confidential student information into a
database um from that third party for
additional actions
and specifically
they have identified
that third party
as
performing a special
um for the district um
yeah i guess what i'm asking
representative is what would those
functions be what are they contracted to
do
um
they are contracted to look at
behavioral issues is my understanding
and when necessary um
offer referral services
so that third party is reaching out to
others if they feel necessary to offer
um referral services to agencies to
address
behavioral issues or mental health
issues um if they do that there is a
requirement in my understanding in their
contract that they have to have parental
notification if they're referring a
student for mental health
follow-up
but there is no requirement um for
uh the parents to be notified in that uh
confidential personal information is
being released to that uh
to that third party to begin with and in
the case of this specific instance that
includes name address and sas
i'm shaking my head because you and i
have had a conversation about this and i
really i know you can't share the
details with me per se but i really want
those details i want to know
what happened and who it was and where
it was
uh
follow up on that
um uh it is my understanding that it's
either six or seven districts in the
state um have a contract under this
federal grant to do this
thank you mr chair um is it a specific
program is it something uh the federal
grant program is called um aware
okay i'll be doing my homework thank you
very much
further discussion
yes represent tanner and then
representative milor thank you does this
um
also apply to
prenda and kai and some of the
as a third party vendor that's
may want
specific
addresses or phone numbers or
whatever of students
no
um can you explain why not
uh
if a parent is um enrolling their child
in any education freedom account
and learning pot of any sorts
the parent
is uh enrolling their child it's uh it's
not um a district function it's a
parental function
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair
um
i guess one of the concerns i have and
there's there's no
question in my mind that parents need to
be informed
but there are there may be situations
where they shouldn't be informed
and
the one of the queries i would have is
if this is particularly related to a
child a student
what are the rights of the student
for confidentiality
in their life as it relates to what's
going on in school
and so
the concern that i have with this
is that if there is an issue
for student confidentiality whether it
be for counseling etc
how does this relate to the protection
of them
because it might be
a conflict that they have with their
parent
that they're seeking resolution
and they don't want their parent to know
the conflict that they've got that
they're trying to resolve
and so i that's the conflict i have with
the language here
that it seems that it's it's fairly
blatant
that regardless of what the situation
might be
that the parent would be informed
regardless of what whether or not
it was specifically the dealing with the
student
and some conflict the student may be
having to try to resolve
so i'm in conflict now with
the parental right to have knowledge of
what's going on as well as a
confidentiality issue
of the right of the student
glenn i'm not sure that you can help me
with that conflict that i'm having right
now
um
if i might
uh i'm not sure if it is in these pages
but
i believe it is in the contract
to my understanding that
if this third party does do the referral
it is required
that there be
and i can't remember if it's written
consent
if the child is under 18
um for the referral or if it's just
parental notification
but i believe that might be in a federal
statute um or certainly in at least the
requirements of this federal grant
um and uh
um
i'm sorry i didn't bring it along
but i do have
more information and there is
information on the doe website about
the aware program and the districts that
are pro
partaking in that program
as a follow-up
do you under do you understand as as the
sponsor of this amendment do you
understand my concern as it relates to
the student
student rights issue on this
right um
but i i think that um
in these cases
the uh third party
contractor if you will
um is taking over a function that would
have been uh provided by the district
um
so i think it's
totally justified to let the parent know
that information is being released
to this third party agency
about that
and i was
shocked to find out that they were
providing sacid numbers
to this um agency
representative woodcock
thank you um
i will defer to reverend sullivan his
hands up first oh i didn't see it go
ahead
with respect uh representative cordelli
you seem to be very focused on the aware
program and i know that's the the
genesis of this uh amendment
um but i'm thinking that
a lot of school districts uh outsource
their um
psychological services
a lot of districts do not
hire their own psycho psychologist or
psychiatrist
and
they would outsource those services
and i guess i'm sharing representative
miller's uh concern that
you know these types of notifications
could create some jeopardy if it is a
psychiatrist or psychologist that is the
um outsourced
service
can you
can you help with that
i think that there are
quite a few provisions of
ferpa
and pupil protection
rights
also
which address that
but i think that
if the student is
i'm not sure what circumstances um
someone who is acting with the
department actually the school district
um
if the school district is referring
someone
to a psychiatrist let's say or a social
worker or anything
i think that there are requirements um
already in law for that both federally
and state
that
uh revolve around parental notification
um i think this is um more limited um in
in scope um
under under ferpa and the exception
exemptions under ferpa
for because these exemptions are
exemptions from requiring parental
consent
so
i'm aware that this does not require
parental consent to release this
information to the third party
but i'm just saying that the parents
should be notified that this is
happening
representative
thank you mr chair um again a question
for representative cordelli do you um
i'm on the doe website so and there is a
treasure trove of information here um
it's the department i mean obviously
this looks like it's a department
initiative so is the department involved
in
this protection of student privacy
yes i've been in contact with the
department and they've talked with the
lawyers
and
they agree that it
falls
within the exemption
under ferpa that we are discussing
but
they are having discussions
um
with the contractors uh to see if they
can
limit some of that information that is
being shared with them
so they are actively involved in those
discussions are ongoing is
my understanding
representing luna
and now yeah representative bowman next
yeah thank you thank you very much mr
chair so in in reference to the um
the federal code
part d 99
um
are does does this amendment
apply to
i guess
every condition in 9931
that
that does not
require prior consent
to in order to disclose the information
okay i'm looking to follow where you are
99 31. um in particular um i'm looking
at
b the contractor consultant
language that is included in the bill as
well
under under b there it further describes
under you know one two three etc
about that provision
thank you
all right
represent bone
thank you mr chair
the parents are responsible for their
children they need to know what's going
on
with their children in the case of if it
goes to some kind of a psychologist or a
medical
aren't there medical insurance for the
parents probably going to have to pay
unless it's dcyf or something like that
or abuse then the parents need to know
there are other laws which say if it's
if their children are being abused there
are other laws that take care of that
without the parents knowing but the
problem is the parents are responsible
so they need to know what is going on
with their children it is not the
school's responsibility to take care of
the children the parents all have thank
you
representative mullen
thank you
the department of education
it says in 2022 the new hampshire
department of education continues to
lead this effort through the office of
social emotional wellness it's part of
the mtssb the multi-tiered
system of
behavioral support
which
you all will remember senate bill 135
which i think was three years ago four
years ago maybe even now um
established the bureau of student
wellness and the multi-tiered support
system there there are four goals listed
here and uh the fourth one is to
substantially improve the engagement of
school
families and youth in decision making
policy and practice development
and individual needs so they actually
there there's a whole strand in here
about the focus on the family i think
that part of the bureau of student
wellness has been to
engage the family in the decision making
project uh and again it it's reaffirmed
in 2022 so uh in collaboration with the
department of health and human services
so this is something that is well known
to
the doe
so if we have questions about whether or
not there have been legal challenges or
whatever i would say that
governor
governor diana is in the back of the
room and i wouldn't mind hearing from
her on this
let's let's hear from the lieutenant
governor here first
go ahead
thank you i i'm not
i didn't mean to indicate that there
were any legal challenges
i'm not sure
how many people have
been in contact with the department of
education
um about this
but i am familiar with one particular uh
counselor who i have
had a great many discussions with i i
think we talked about it as well
um who
um was very concerned about this
information being provided having to
provide this information to the third
party
without the parents knowing about it
and that what is what set in motion
discussions with department and
everything else and unfortunately
there's not been a resolution to the
satisfaction of this counselor and she
has
since resigned from the school district
prior to getting the doe up here if
they're well willing to come i have a
question um
when i was dealing with high school
students we
had
some i went through a couple of not many
where we had to write a functional
behavioral
assessment
and that's contracted out with a
an individual counselor a psychologist
or other medical folks that are capable
of doing that and then
we we follow followed up with a behavior
management plan within the school
and we have to identify whether the
behavior was a manifest of the
iep handicapping condition
we oftentimes involved health and human
services in doing this
um
in doing this and we had some situations
where
the parent really wasn't available
um and they were just sad situations so
would we be be holding to this here
where we had to do the 10-day
notification and
before we could get that man uh the the
whole process started i i don't think
you
if you give me the liberty of answering
that question um
somebody is responsible for that child
there's no way that a functional
behavioral analysis is taking place
without
permission
because that's part of the special ed
process
yes yes so uh so that's going to be
covered under idea so somebody whether
it's dcyf
a legal guardian a parent somebody has
to give permission for that
and this the project aware money is is
money that came through
samsa which is drug and alcohol
treatment programs
i'm sure that there are school districts
that have been looking for assistance
because they have
parents who are deeply involved and kids
who need help as a result of it but um
yeah i
uh i certainly believe in the protection
of privacy and i also believe uh to
representative boehm's point that
parents are key to kids mental health
but i also know that we have uh
you know
not an insignificant amount of families
not just
children that people are working with
without the knowledge of their moms and
dads i mean
families that are grateful for the help
that's being given to them families that
are looking
to schools as a purveyor of information
on where to go to get help
so um
you know my that's what i did for a
living so my experience was
very different i'm representative
cordelia will tell you that i was
horrified at the aspect of
some counselor being forced into sharing
private information against their
professional judgment or
but
i
don't know that we have
i don't know that the need is there
again you know this comes back to
where are the instances of issue
why are we putting something into effect
if it has not
happened to any degree i mean there's
always going to be a
a counselor that
you know has a questionable call an
administrator that does something that
someone questions the call
that's going to happen but
unfortunately i don't think the solution
is to craft laws uh based on individual
situations
do you still need to talk to the
department
uh i would like to know
thank you representative mullen do you
have a i do thank you mr chair and thank
you attorney fenton for taking the hot
seat again
i wouldn't miss this opportunity yes i'm
sorry that you have to dodge the speaker
in order to talk to me but uh
so my question are you aware of the the
bill and the amendment to this bill
uh the amendment to 352 okay
so my ques it looks like representative
cordelie's concern is that
student privacy
is both at risk
and that somehow or another parents are
unaware of the fact that either their
kids are participating in this program
or
from my reading what i'm seeing is that
it looks like it is a school-wide
program but funded through drug and
alcohol monies
and perhaps targeted to students with
significant behavioral and emotional
challenges
the question is do we need to is
are you getting complaints or concerns
or
is there a legal need to do uh
what we're proposing here
so for the record my name is diana
fenton i'm with the department of
education um
i can't answer the last part of your
question is there a legal need um what i
can answer is um is the department aware
of any
lawsuits that we've received pertaining
to this particular issue none that i'm
aware of
i'm not aware of any
um complaints as it relates to that
particular program um the aware program
as administered by the office of student
wellness um you know
presumably i would be made aware of such
things but i i don't want to sit here
and promise you that there's there's
never been a complaint about it but to
the best of my knowledge no we have not
gotten any of those complaints
further questions from the committee of
the department
thank you
oh you got one rep santana i i can't let
diana go without a question
um do you feel that
parents um
right over the student privacy issue is
thank you is uh
is sufficient at this point
without it
with
that's covered under
current law that that if there was a
case uh similar to what representative
cordelia's talking about that there
would be sufficient way to
deal with that through
legal issues
uh governed by the
the ferpa laws
i mean i i think that the ferpa laws
are sufficient as written but i think
there's a reason that this amendment has
been brought forward so clearly there is
an issue that is not being addressed or
else this amendment wouldn't be brought
forward the particulars of that
obviously lie with representative
cordelli but
i trust in the constituent that brought
it to his attention that there was a
need to address it there will always
inevitably be
loopholes and and inevitable holes in
every law um they cannot account for
every conceivable fact pattern that will
arise is there a process
uh that if someone felt as though rather
than come
to place something in statute is there a
process for a counselor that was in that
situation to come to the doe or make a
complaint to
some sort of federal agency about this
rather than
create another statute
the state doe receives many complaints
on on a whole host of topics um i would
like to think that we're a fairly open
state agency i know we hear from an
enormous number of people and i know
we've worked with our counterparts in
boston the usdoe and i know that they
receive complaints on a variety of
issues from people
in terms of this particular issue i mean
it's
i'm not sure i don't know all the
details and particulars of it
um but i'm not aware of anyone who has
tried to approach our office
as it relates to this
exact issue
i guess mike what i meant was is there
is there
if your privacy is being
breached
or the privacy of your child is being
and you find out about it
there is legal recourse for that isn't
there there is legal recourse and and we
have received
we have received um
concerns as it pertains to ferpa not
this exact fact pattern um but i can
share with you that that there was a
school district just this past week that
had a ferpa violation and they reported
it to the department of education and
they believed it fell within their
obligation under the code of conduct
they reported us we worked with um they
reported to us we worked with that
district to make sure that that issue
had been remedied the district had
already taken care of it taken
appropriate steps and and we felt that
it had been rectified appropriately so
yes um
districts and individuals will report to
us on
on
ferpa type issues yes
further questions yes represent cordelia
um
thank you
um for being here um
uh would it be correct that um
in terms of complaints
um a parent would have to know that this
was going on
before they could uh call the department
with a complaint
it would be hard for them to report
otherwise thank you i would imagine
further questions
once again thank you very much thank you
any further discussion on the amendment
yes represent hall
thank you
for taking my question to the chair i'd
just like to respond to a comment that
representative baum you made when you
said it's not the school's
responsibility to take care of the
children
truly in 40 years in the classroom for
me
i always thought it was my
responsibility to take care of those
children and my own children going
through the school system when they were
at school i expected that the school
would take care of my children so i just
wanted to respond to that thank you
further discussion
not seeing any
so we have a motion on the floor as otp
on the amendment 1697 h
madam clerk would
you we can either show our hands or
either way on this
okay may i see a show of hands on
amendment 16 97 h
six please
nine nine
okay it's nine to nine or yeah nine to
nine
all those which were opposed you know we
didn't get you to put your hands up but
i assume it's the opposite way
you can't abstain
so we have nine to nine the amendment
does not pass
so we're at the main motion right now
and that's uh 352 relative substitute
teacher criminal history records checks
check
we haven't had a whole lot of discussion
on the bill itself
in terms of moving it or uh would you
like
just discussion on it do you is there
any
this just discussion okay
um yeah i mean i think that the
purpose of this bill is to streamline
for substitute teachers
the criminal background check process so
that they don't
have to uh
repeat the criminal the background check
repeatedly
i i don't see a problem with it i know
that school districts are having a devil
of a time getting substitute teachers so
i think that if a substitute teacher
passes a criminal background check in
one
part of the sau then they ought to be
able to work throughout
further discussion
not seeing any the motion was made by
believe representative cordelian
seconded by representative boehm
not seeing any further discussion
madam clerk get your hand up ralph
okay madam clerk would you please call
the roll
yes we are voting on sb 352
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
oh representative
yes representative lakis yes represent
moffett yes joseph hobson
represent ford yes representative saudi
yes represent milor yes representative
luno yes
president of sullivan yes representative
tanner yes represent allison yes
represent mullen yes
represent woodcock yeah
representative lane yes represent
yes and chairman vlad yes
that motion passes 18-0
consent
thank you
i think that takes us to the bottom of
the agenda
any comments in our comment period here
okay
well we have done all the bills that
have come before us
so that's 103 from the
hb side and from the senate bill side we
had 13 so there there's our total
116 bills
good job
so we are done
yes i know it's done
thank you very much have a great
afternoon what's left of it
yeah
just a quick comment um um i want to
thank you for um for your leaders
committee leadership in getting us
through a hundred and
sixteen bills and i know that's an
extraordinary scheduling load mel and i
went through it two years ago with about
half that number of bills and scheduling
half that number of bills is a challenge
so um
so
yeah thank you very much for a kid when
i was in grade school in first grade i
couldn't tell a b from a p
and a little bit of that dyslexia and
when you're dealing with so many numbers
and so many bills that some creeps up on
you when you get tired but i i thank you
and i thank everybody here for hanging
in there we had some very very long days
as you recall four or five days a week
and so keep track of our senate bills
over there the senate always trying to
do a number on us
so
keep keep on top of it there's another
bill dealing with similar topics you're
interested in um reps and mullen it's
416. just edwards has it in his
committee
and it's dealing with
um
the area of these manifest education you
know and the costs of it and all that so
you might want to give it a check
but thank you very much to everybody
else and have a great afternoon hey and
uh and a quick plug plug that uh shannon
reed wanted me to um to just bring out i
i know it's getting late tonight but uh
but nhgi is holding two exhibitions of
student work one tonight
at gripone hall from four to seven pm
and one on thursday
the 28th from five to seven the the
thursday one is a
it is a a college-wide exhibition
it was i think held for the first time
prior to the pandemic i attended it it
was very well attended
um and it was just fantastic and um and
the last couple years it has been on
hiatus and um and now it's now it's back
so thursday pony also acropony yep so
thank you okay great
have a good one
you